[Music]
day three of the second leg of the grand
chess tour here in leuven it was a huge
day of blitz with nine rounds of
lightning fast play from 10 of the best
players in the world gm wesley so could
not maintain his unbeaten record from
the first two days of rapid but he
bounced back after each loss with a win
to solidify his second place standing in
the event
world champion magnus carlson was
looking to run away from the field but
he faced stiff resistance and could only
maintain a slim one point lead going
into the final game
the title is on the line with the giants
of chess battling it out to see who will
be king
day four action starts right now
now
[Music]
hello everyone i'm alejandra ramirez
here in the city of leuven just outside
of brussels normally this is known as a
college town with 50 000 people enrolled
in the university behind me they're
absolutely gorgeous library that dates
back to the 15th century however today
this city is known for its chess as
we're in the fourth and final day here
in belgium in more exciting games of
blitz for more information we go back to
the studio with jen yassen eric
thank you alejandra i'm jennifer shahady
i'm here with yasser sarwan hello
jennifer delighted to be with you as
always
yes and we're so excited because
yesterday was such a tight day right
absolutely well the strongest tournament
ever held in belgium has delivered
and it's a race to the finish and it's
in a and a pack of people
anybody could win this event yeah let's
take a look at the standings as we move
into the final day of the grand chester
in lubin
well magnus carlson we just saw our
world champion sitting down and he's got
17 points he's a point ahead of the
field wesley so as a runner-up he had a
real autopsy to every day yesterday
every time he lost its horrible game he
seemed to come back with an equally cool
win and indeed that's exactly what
happened the look of lavon ironian in
third place he scored five and a half
out of the nine points available
yesterday can he do it again well five
and a half was the most points that
anyone got in the blitz if you look at
the blitz score column you'll see that
it's so um clumped up there right right
almost everybody has plus one even or
minus one and that's quite unusual in
blitz as we saw in a player's segment um
where they were all interviewed about
blitz they talked about how streaky
blitz tends to be and i think we're
gonna see more of that today absolutely
and just still noting that carl nakamura
scored five but still
way way off the uh pace for him i don't
think a plus one is enough no he wanted
more than plus one and let's take a look
at our format
you'll notice that these scores are a
combination of the rapid which took
place on uh friday and saturday
and the blitz so there are nine points
left at stake
one point for each blitz game and two
points for each rapid game there is a
playoff there's a tie for first yes
and we've got a grand master eric hanson
with his thoughts on what we're going to
see today do you agree we're going to
see more streaks
i do think we're going to see more
streaks i think we're going to see more
risk taking uh magnus he he's he's got a
point lead he's the favorite but without
a doubt the trailing pack senses blood
any weakness they're going to pounce on
it i'm going to be watching out for who
wants it badly who's ready to you know
avoid bad blunders put up a lot of
resistance
i mean really four players have a
realistic shot of winning but with more
insights and comments let's head to the
guys in leuven
well in paris at this point it was a
two-horse race it was clear that nobody
else had a chance but now we actually
have three players and maybe even a
fourth with an outside chance clearly
magnus carlsen has the lead he has a
point so he is in control of his own
destiny but as we saw yesterday he did
have hiccups and if he does that today
he's not going to win the tournament he
had a couple of losses yesterday which
is something that he can't afford to do
today he needs to stay to the field i'm
here i'm here to play good chess i just
want to score enough points and nobody
can catch me wesley so is only one point
behind him that's pretty close already
in one and a half points it's not that
much in blitz we've seen how streaky
players can get magnus had a bad finish
in paris he needs to make sure that here
in leuven he actually finishes with a
good score absolutely so we expect the
players to be on form they know they can
catch him and so it's going to be tight
it's going to be tense and of course
we're going to be here to follow all the
action
that's right and let's look at the
pairings for our first round today we've
got lavon oronion versus magnus carlsen
and that's the game that we're going to
be keeping absolutely that's a marquee
matchup right there right below them
carl nakamura mbl those two players need
to make their move and karo really needs
to get on the street to climb back in
but wesley sew
in second place he's playing vladimir
kramnik and anything can happen and i'm
looking forward to a great finish
that's right i think that lavon aronia
and magnus carlson's really gonna
show a lot about how the rest of the day
is gonna go yes and who's in forum and
and similarly um two really legendary uh
blitz players we see with maxime and uh
and uh
yes and of course we have these same
pairings in the first round of the blitz
in the last cycle
and we saw that um the game between
lavon and magnus was a well-played draw
indeed it was i thought for a while
there that uh
uh the advantages were slipping back and
forth but as you say well played draw
fewer fewer mistakes and there you see
the players being introduced
us champion fabiano cariwan is stepping
on stage
that's right
if you remember there was also that game
between um
maximum dashier lagrange nakamura which
was a real thriller act yes
when mdl failed as black to
lower the boom he had a big advantage in
that game right
indeed and we see malcolm hayne of the
grand chester or the london chess
classic organizer
he's introducing vaseline
and vishy and two great rivals
[Applause]
trying to get rid of his blunders
which he's
doing he's been doing much better
one thing i was going to mention i think
magnus really needs to improve his white
pieces today yesterday he found himself
in big trouble against mvl and anand
so that's going to be an easy fix if you
can either improve the opening or play
something different whereas wesley so
needs to improve his black pieces he got
rolled over by magnus and kramnik so the
top two players there both have been you
know looking to solidify a bit and play
more solidly
with uh different colors
that was a good handshake uh fire world
champion magnus carlson and lavonna
and that will again be our marquee
matchup now lavone
uh in paris he didn't distinguish
himself
but here he's got a real chance and if
he if he can maintain the form
of yesterday there'll be a real threat
for first place that's right look at
these cute kids wearing their i heart
chest shirts oh
yes i heart chest to you guys
and let's see what they're going to play
for lavon it's a joint effort they're
fighting yes yes i like it e2e4
with a big smile
but somehow i don't think he's going to
play that move
magnus yeah baby bring it
bring in his sicilian sicilian part
three right we have been seeing uh
magnus played the sicilian notably
against uh wesley so
getting a good position in that game
and lavon says he's
no gonna no he's gonna freak pull that
one back and i'm expecting a queen
yeah levon's one of the few players in
the field who hasn't been mixing up the
repertoire too much as white he's been
avoiding e4 for the most part sticking
with
d4 and occasionally c4 i've been really
impressed by magnus magnus has been
mixing up his defenses basically more
than anybody essaying kingpon classical
king pond defenses as well as sicilians
and even akaru
just to make things a little bit more
interesting look at this
stonewall dutch knight h3 very popular
move a move made very popular pardon me
by anatoly karpov the idea of the
strange move is to support a future
bishop f4 should black play bishop d6
and there we see it bishop d6
and normally my board will catch up in a
second normally we see bishop f4 coming
so and there you go right and bishop e7
backing up the trade of dark squared
bishop is usually considered quite
favorable for white right because then
we're left with just that eyesore on c8
yes exactly
now here that doesn't even look good at
four in the morning
i mean it is it is in the united states
exactly now here this uh standard setup
is to play queen c2
and prepare
an f3 e4 break in the center
and what's block's plan
exactly that is a big question what is
black's plan
normally speaking there's an h6 g5 idea
as well as a b6 bishop b7
a big
for both players is what happens with
this knight on h3 if it remains offsides
then it's going to be a very nice game
comfortable game for black but if it
ever gets to a big square like f4 and
there we see the h6 g5 planned by magnus
coming up
but if if it remains out of the game
black's going to do great if he gets in
the game
white's going to be doing great it's
really that simple
one thing i've noticed magnus likes to
do when he plays a stonewall is push
that a pawn when he's when given the
chance he's had a memorable game where
he's pushed it to a3 and
and one i believe in vikanze but uh it's
usually combined with that b6 plan
sometimes yeah not so much the g5 plan
and we saw knight c3 and basically black
is being challenged to capture this pawn
but it's usually a very bad idea
uh in these positions so i don't expect
any upon grubbing this early
by the world champion
right and uh
who do you prefer playing in these
positions definitely it's definitely
easier to play white
does anyone prefer playing black
magnus carlson
i mean the stonewall is
it works in maybe these top controls but
still doesn't have the best reputation
for equalizing and there you go g5 and
it's definitely all about this knight on
h3
as
black is basically trying to
encourage what looks like the obvious
move bishop to e5
but then what black is
going to try to do is play knight d7 and
end up capturing this bishop once it
gets to the e5 square a funny line
is that sometimes there's really good
reasons to play the move bishop c7 and
we saw bishop e5 that's right i thought
you were going to take them b and i'm
like no yes sir don't do it don't do it
and now the point is is if you play
bishop bishop c7 here you force black to
spend some time
hunting down that bishop
a completely different plan
is this idea of capturing on d5 with the
idea of eyeballing this pawn on f5 the
problem is is there are lots of
variations where your queen and that
queen ends up getting trapped by
capturing this pawn too early
so
things are warming up here and i'm just
well there's a possible variation you
play cd5 ed5 queen f5 you can do that a
possible continuation furthermore would
be knight e5
if we i guess yes
c d so you're saying c c takes because
it's not favorable for black to take
with the c pawn right no definitely five
or something so ed5 is probably what
magnus
is planning and then queen f5 knight e5
uh-huh queen e5 and now knight g4 is
very strong
very strong move the queen is forced to
go to c7 not a very good square and the
point is white black is has good
competition knight on h3 is pretty bad
you can't kick it out with f3 so that's
just uh playing for compensation maybe
rook f7 there yeah
bishop b4 or something but
quite um yeah and again uh this this
pawns on g6 h6 acting as a fence
uh corralling this knight on h3 instead
in the game um
has played the move f3
probably knight f2 at some point but
usually black is happy if you can win
the dark sword bishop on e5
definitely definitely i like the i like
the position for magnus uh
uh coming coming out of the opening he's
given himself chances and as you said he
played
he's played almost every opening and
that's uh pretty impressive that's one
advantage he has that he's getting good
positions with with sidelines that's
right and he's playing a lot of
aggressive openings a lot of openings
where there's crazy attacks on both
sides so that's fun to see so he has a
captured that bishop on e5 you did 100.
some some kind of advantage in the clock
for magnus but kind of small f4 to be
played after and then what you do as
black with the two bishops you have to
figure out how to open up the position
and it looks like why you played f4 and
the magnus responded with taking on c4
whoa
yeah but you can get an update
taking on c4
okay that is
i i mean i i really admire uh magnus's
ability to mix it up but that might be
just a bridge too far it's inviting e4
yes it is
i thought he was going to maintain his
pawn on d5 lavon started with knight b1
actually just kind of um highlighting
the attack on the c4 pawn and
note that b5 allows bishop takes c6
right so if you want to hang on to that
pawn for dear life you're going to have
to play knight v6 but then after knight
d2 i'm rounding it up anyway precisely
but in those positions where we're just
stopping there knight b6 knight b2
there's a bishop c5 check and a bishop
e3 that could be potentially annoying i
like that i like maybe even throwing in
g4 uh at some point too in one of those
lines after king h1 g4 knight g1 then
bishop e3 yes
well actually now that we've mentioned
it why not simply start with bishop c5
check
that's uh a strong move
and magnus going under two minutes in
this position bishop c5 king h1 and then
he's
four he took on f4
now
recapture with the pawn you did yeah
and knight f
96 yes as expected
well since that b-pawn isn't going away
there's a there's some good reasons for
starting with a move like king h1
uh
to be followed by e4 but uh just knife
e2 just simply knight d2 okay
so there is again this
option for black to play bishop c5 check
and bishop e3
i'm sure there's going to be some
sacrifices coming up like an exchange
sacrifice you mentioned the eyesore on
of the bishop on c8 well it's still on
c8
magnus just went 95. yes i take c4
um
now he's playing king h8 he's ready to
get his rook to g8 right he's trying to
run up in attacking that way king h1
king h1 is a very reasonable
ga queen h5 is how black wants to follow
up
i think that even though we're not
playing with our bishop in our rook
right i think at some moment uh lavon
wants to spank down knight d6
and probably just even take that knight
on d5 well they're giving us our money's
worth in this game definitely it's a
full-blooded battle bishop
trying to prevent um permanently the
queen h5 idea i like it quick bishop d7
by magnus he's now keeping a head on the
clock putting the pressure on the bond
who's downtown g7 what if now king h1
definitely that gets my uh that's it
that's what levon played yes rook g8
rook g1 queen f7 seems like
but then you know but white is just like
uh building up for a knight d6 that's
why that's true h3 is still not that
good so if you write knight d6 i might
take and play queen f6
okay
throw the knight on h3 yeah he just
tossed out knight knight d6
strategically very nice move but that
knight on h3
as we've been speaking about uh for some
time
it's
it's got a direct path knight f2 to d3
to e5 so it takes time takes time to get
there
things open if you take on e5 it's nice
that queen takes t5 attacks on d6
that's the pawn we went around up
absolutely and 93
yes
93 would be in the position
well i'm
thinking about bishop takes d5
c takes d5 takes on e5
he took on this 25 to start and then
after queen e5 he played this move queen
c5 disallowing knight e3 because of the
pin
protecting d6
maybe trying to take on a a6 a7 as well
but what about
well bishop b6 is what magnus played
just putting pressure on d6
lavon quickly um captured an a7 so now
rook f7 maybe you're going to take g6
next move
well um yes your work f7 was played you
got it eric
and then there was a retreat to the
queen to d4 and a trade on d4 so queen's
off the board
and what is going on 30 seconds for
lavon
just under a minute for carlson and
knight f4 is a big strategic move
very good move i didn't see that one
rook f7 to d7
delaying the capture on d6
and then we've got
d1
and 93 um on add one by the way rook d1
knight e3
rook d3 knight c4 all these moves have
been played knight f4 that big time move
knight c4 rod not c2 not knight c4
okay knight c4 and the knight f4 that
big time move you were mentioning yes
and it looks like bishop f7 bishop h5
creeping and crawling into black's
position bishop h5
so what's the surprise move there i
didn't expect him to snapping on b2 so
now rook h3 looks very sharp
e3 came very quickly
now knight c4 again well then we've got
rook e7 perhaps and he did play knight
c4 again so we're gonna find out and now
he's changed his mind and played your
original idea
oh that was a big waste of tempo
concessionary
so the idea being that after what takes
d6 well oh we're going to see it work
takes d6 um
unfortunately um maybe no knight takes
d6 maybe we need to switch to um your
board because we've got okay we're good
now
rook takes d6 knight takes d6 um we
should probably get caught up yeah i'm
just uh we actually see the um the
overhead shot here right
uh a little piece of magnet one
magnificent pawn now yeah
and the a4 pawn is really weak so this
is a very favorable end game for black
you're just going to round up uh the a4
pawn and then d6 glitzing away eight
seconds uh eight seconds to 24.
world champion this is very hard to hold
this is very hard to hold with such a
weak isolated pawn on a4 and such a
strong knight on d6
whoa
just got missed i
oh no
no it didn't okay there was something
but it looks like some blunder did
happen some blunders did indeed happen
oh big blunder happened
so
yeah so i understand so there was a
there was a hanging rook on d4 so he
wasn't able to take the knight but he
did manage to get his pawn back as a
result of that
of his own he's got this h4 pawn
going up the board but this does look
like a drawn
rook and pawn right it's rook and two
verse rook into
um levana has his advances pawn
both both players are racing with their
palms by the way crown trying to get his
key into the game kram defeat wesley so
oh for the second day in the room big
result very big result magnet's going
down on time now
amazing
and just and the draws have been agreed
wrong
whoa
a crazy draw actually keeping us on the
edge of our seats right let's see if
there's any games left absolutely
there's time
another big match up let's see where
they're standing
well
it looks like an ending where black's
got um connect well not connected with
some very dangerous looking ponds
and
he's trying to infiltrate here
whoa
but
the idea is that if we can't we've got
some kind of rookie forest off no
there's just king g3 would take that
pawn on g2
well he's gonna which he has done he has
and then he's going to stop him
it's over
all black has to do is give up his rook
for the a pawn and the two pass pawns on
f4 and g4 will carry the day
and if king b3 hat you're just going to
move your rook on rook to h2
it looks like um
rook h2 is the simplest move
as has played
and all you've got to do is right right
rook to h8 or whatever you played
virtually
there was that move with a4 and this is
resigned this is resigns
uh you know hikaru was an emotional
uh player but i haven't seen him
actually hit a chair after a loss what
he just did there oh wow yeah
we haven't seen the whole game so
perhaps it has something to do with what
was going on earlier in the game and i'm
sure the guy's moving will probably fill
us in that as well
but he certainly looks like somebody who
had a misfortune in that game well big
results uh will have to just uh go
through them there okay so wesley lost
west
but um you know mpl's not doing that
well in the competition so even though
he's getting up to 13 and a half not a
huge threat yet
but the big news is that um drew a worse
position that's right a losing position
a losing position even at one moment
but and we're going to head over to
leuven for some thoughts on the round
excellent
well clearly some big results this round
certainly magnus carlsen as we saw that
featured game getting a draw keeping a
solid situation with aronian giving
chase with a draw himself so both sides
not too unhappy but certainly wesley so
with the white pieces of that losing to
vladimir krom they cannot be happy at
all as he blundered at the very end
that's gotta have a sour taste since the
start of the day it was a dream round
almost for magnus cause and had he
actually converted against the earnings
he would have increased this lead
tremendously with his closest rival
losing against vladimir kramnik and
magnus causes could have taken care of
aronian himself instead still maybe some
chances for the field wesley stark
committed a lot of mistakes but i think
the decisive one started with this move
queen to b1 kramnik essayed a very
typical variation for him he sacrificed
upon early in the opening got a good
bishop eventually got his pawn back but
the trouble for wesley really started
with this move queen b1 very careless he
should have played rook c2 and then boom
after rook c8 you start to see this spin
on the c file and this is something that
was just
there for the entire game i'm gonna go
through quickly uh on the moves but just
notice how through the entire game the c
file is a problem for the white pieces
already two pieces against the knight
this ties both of white's rooks against
this knight on c3 which cannot move and
a brilliant idea here by kramnik he
shatters the pawn structure on the
king's side by sacrificing upon allowing
any end game to really be won
wesley tried to hold on as best as he
could brings the king in to try to break
the pin and although he had some chances
to hold the the draw here in this
position after rook d7 check 94 rook
takes g3 it seems like wesley's worse
definitely worse the pawn on g5 is the
big problem but okay he got his knight
to d4 he's stabilizing a little bit it
looks i mean it looks okay right now
other than the g-pawn it looks like he
should be able to survive and he'd crawl
back into the game basically right but
this pin and the defense took a big toll
on his time by this point wesley was
down to seconds whereas kramnik had more
than a minute left and that well that's
from the pressure on the position after
rook b5 which was a huge blunder rook
takes d4 was played by kramnik
exploiting the pin on the third rank
which means black wins a piece and the
game wesley so cannot be happy about the
start here in blitz chess the time is
almost like a piece it's like being up a
minute when it's under a minute it's
almost like being down a piece so you
can't say well he just blundered no
you've got to manage your clock time
because you will make mistakes the
position chess is just simply too
complicated for us to figure everything
out with only seconds ticking on the
clock but another important game of
course was a game with anan against
topalov anand he's got a hard road to
climb first trying to get to magnus
carlsen he's two and a half points
behind to start the day but no better
way to start now than to win a nice game
against basilica i'm not a very
cold-blooded player and i really like
how he handles possession we could move
28 for uh white and it seems like black
might be creating some kind of threat
here on the king's side he has his rooks
here his queen here his bishops on this
side and anand just really doesn't care
um after recapturing here he simply
pushed his pawn up and even though
topalov tried to create some kind of
counterplay here on this side of the
board anand just did not care at all he
simply promoted his pawn he said okay
take my pawn i really don't care i just
moved my king away and because of this
beautiful rook on a3 there is no idea of
queen g3 or anything similar and the
game was just over just to continue this
line he could deflect the queen with
this move and now it looks like
unstoppable mate except oops it's his
move first and that would just have been
me in two to close out the game so anan
with a very important win
we saw that tail ender maxim vashila
grav
well nakamura that is lose to maxim
vashi lagrave i thought that nakamura
would have some chances to maybe play
spoiler and that can still happen but he
really started off today in just a
miserable way this was not a very good
game for nakamura he actually came with
an opening surprise basher was actually
down a minute from the opening because
uh
bachelorette uh played the night dwarf
yesterday against carlson and in that
same variation that were prepared a
novelty played it over the board and
version had to start to think what to do
and actually uh nakamura got an extra
pawn at some point he was in the
driver's seat through most of the game
and he just messed it up in the endgame
maxine was better in time pressure at
the end and took the full point so that
really means that the winner from paris
is looking like he's not going to make
any headway i don't know how many points
he'd have to collect to move up any
significant way in the standings luckily
for him you could toss out one of the
results in the grand chess tour so this
will probably be that result for him for
sure while the others are kind of
jostling to see what position they might
take we saw fabiano and anish play their
game and so those those games will
probably not be paying too much
attention to because it's really all
about this four horse race with magnus
aronian
so and anand back to you in the studio
thank you guys well talk about stan
starting with the bang and let's have a
look at those results
of the first round right well now magnus
is up
one and a half points over the field um
that's a big change he needs to continue
to distance himself if he wants to
secure a victory yeah thanks to wesley's
look lost lebron's draw lavon um moves
up in the tie vichy
with a win also moving up and mvl still
on the outside but what a
what an opening uh tussle there
nice yeah between
and magnus and indeed and we'll be uh
right back with uh the next round
[Music]
hello and welcome back to
the louvre in the final stop of the
grand chess tour begin there with uh
lavon and magnus just told us how yes
and definitely magnus had the better of
it uh he missed a clear win we felt on
our break eric and i were just looking
at if he kind of pointed that move c6 e5
if he had played knight c4 it looks
really bad for levon so big miss there
for the world champion but a big game
coming up now but really the game could
have gone either way i mean it was just
crazy for a while and then lavon messed
up a little bit with that like rook e3
then to h3 yeah i think it was balanced
at that point but i didn't really see
levonnes having winning chances the same
winning chances that magnus had and here
we have the games underway we'll keep an
eye on this um all-american battle
between fabiano kawarana and wesley so
but mostly we're going to keep an eye a
big eye on our world champion who was
playing against vessel and tobola this
round who lost his first game we talked
about streaks
vessel and known for his streaks and
in in this particular case he's also
playing against magnus with the black
pieces
you've got two blacks to start the final
day and it looks like a grunt valve yeah
this is a popular one in the greenfield
you sacrifice a pawn as black for some
compensation get the two bishops and
easy development
so usually his white plays e3
uh bishop c4na g to e2 that would be a
common uh way of playing and it's uh in
some ways similar to that panel botfinic
line where white
keeps a pawn up
yeah exactly that's a
that's exactly uh right there eric that
uh
that pawn sacrifice i've always felt a
little bit
uh shaky when i'm white uh the dynamic
play for
for for black i think this is
interesting
i won a game in gibraltar a couple of
years back with this but the main line
is castling before taking on c5 it's
absolutely your king's not stuck on the
side but uh so what do you think of this
move king f8 you want to show us eric
well no it's just just uh you can castle
your king the g7 there's
the king is safe either way on the dark
squares but um a lot of people prefer
castling
that's just the main line well let me
just think that fate is what i did i had
a game like this i just didn't get full
compensation i try to play a6 uh b5 try
to play before try to undermine pieces
defending the d5 square
we have seen one thing about black is
the play is very easy because you're
down upon a vessel is very comfortable
in in that regard playing down the pawn
as long as he has a lot of activity so
you'll see king g7 bishop f5 rook d8 and
a6 and just a lot of pressure on as i
said the pieces defending the d5 pawn
and also probably yeah you just want to
dislodge that knight away from c3 but
generally
speaking it's a bit better for white but
good counter chances for black and i
like the choice in a blitz game
a lot
indeed i i was gonna ask you that uh we
sometimes we see vessel and get into
positions which aren't his cup of tea
but this one being uh
being it but i know yes or you might
disagree because you love the pond well
i mean i objectively believe it's not
enough compensation
but
we've seen upon isn't that that much of
a big deal so far
time is of course a big factor but at
the moment uh the players are pretty
even on time so knight d4 nice move you
know because otherwise black would play
bishop f5 maybe knight e4 exactly
and then you always have to worry about
your d3 square as well so
rook d8 instead kind of uh hinting at uh
potential problems that could come up on
d5 and then the very subtle rook b1
threatening b4 less than subtle i think
v4 is just before the telegraph
yeah yeah yeah so queen sees heaven
immediately by vaseline stepping back uh
i was more curious about the move queen
before but yeah yeah i was wondering
about queen before too maybe he was
worried about it
at all
and 94 is what i might consider the key
piece for black is the dark square
bishop that's the main source of
compensation but i'm even looking at
yeah here maybe 94 let's say
i
i'm not sure how
i would play f4 yeah
knight e4 hunting down that vision it
just looks good it looks it looks good
for
four well i'd say i was lost to my game
when i was live so
so you're not suggesting it to the
people at home no okay
but vessel does not normally play the
grunfeld this is a big surprise in that
sense i never seen him play so bishop b5
we have uh no that i think that was just
a variation okay right so after the move
uh rook b1 oh sorry after uh c7 rook c1
b4 ooh
knight takes a4
queen d5 looks kind of box
rook takes c5 queen t
rook takes c5 takes d5 no you can't take
it and there's a fork on c7
so i think vessel and topolof has
overlooked the key tactic here so what
what eric and i were just looking at was
in case of queen e5
rook takes c5 this pawn on d5 is taboo
and you can't play a move like b6
because i'll have knight c6 rook takes
rip takes and at the end of the day
there's a fork on c7 hitting rook and
queen and that's all she wrote and
meanwhile if you take on a4 you have the
annoying d6 flow
at one moment i'm saying if you if you
try to it's if so you can't d6 is
basically a threat here right so that's
a problem
right exactly yikes
down i don't see anything
wrong what did he after did he miss
after ace it was a6 the culprit no he
has a bad position either way i
i think
too many uh queen moves in b6 and then
queen a5 is a key loss of
tempo we've seen that
lavon earlier in the day and the first
round uh did that
oops and what has happened let's take
that's i'm going to refresh my board
i've flipped to one board and i'll flip
back
uh to update and we're in this position
vessel and topple off to play
nah i'm not a big fan
uh
of uh
the move queen b8
he has played well the truth is there
are no really good moves for him no
no even if he was a computer um exactly
and he did play the move b6
so now
it'll give him his best chances knight
c6 queenie four and things get a bit
sharp that's what he's banking on after
96 queen e4 and if you take on d8 black
takes on uh c5 and the bishops become
very active there's moves like bishop g4
coming tonight on d8 being hit so knight
c6 may not be the best move after b6
he's definitely tempting magnus
to play that i see
but well knight c6 looks so knight c6
queen e4 yeah that looks like the right
way to go but then then uh d5 is with
tempo if you move your knight away
exactly so you're forced to take on d
otherwise you're allowed to rook d5
right and now bishop g4 is a threat and
i'm taking well like that knight cc well
magnus has to scoot the knight c6 he
hasn't played it right away he did not
97 i'd still play bishop g4 yeah i
wasn't in time to play 98 check right
okay sorry it looks like he's just pat
passed in that opportunity well i think
yeah 97 is a threat by pulling the rook
back
black still can't take back on d5 right
and bishop b7 now knight c6
and max is trying to get into a
better uh again the whole point is this
bishop c6 rook c6
you've always got to keep a watchful eye
over that fork of the knight c7 that's
right and then there's also the b6 pawn
which is no choice very hard to defend
so after
after takes on c6 rook takes c5
yes with the tempo against the queen
that's good news
[Music]
bishop c6 rook c6 rook d5 queen c2 yes
rook d8
maybe 94
i think i think white wants to transfer
that knight from b5 all the way back to
f3 controlling the d2 square so well
glass has played work b8 yes
rook
b8 just right work uh yeah
okay yeah well then magnus
i'm happy with this at all this is uh
well he's got an extra part and now he's
driving control now he's just playing
with h3 ooh h3 i thought there was might
might be an opportunity to go i think we
might be missing one move i think
there's a queen b3 and
rook d2 was played yes the queen is on
p3 after rook d5
uh-huh
he didn't play queens no he played three
sorry rook b8 h3 rook d2 and now rook c2
magnus looking trade off it's not the
easiest conversion
i'm a fan of this knight d4 move which
happened i want to transfer it to c6 or
to f3
well and then be able to push the
queen side and vessel and talk on c2
queen takes c2 and that's our that's our
current position
so uh just upon for magnets i could
definitely see knight f3 rook b1 kind of
playing on the light squares playing
avoiding that bishop on f6
okay i would expect to move like queen
d6
yes a yeah attack against the d4 knight
so queen d6 what if knight c6 that's
going to happen and i suppose you've got
to play a move like rook d7 or
maintaining the well that's right g8
doesn't help because you can always just
press
i think this is very bad because rookies
have been cementing tonight anyway well
b5 occurred
now it's time to go queen a3 and
do some kind of just be annoying yes
exactly and he has played it is uh
uh trying to create as many problems for
his opponent as possible
but rookie won this queen b2 rook b1 was
played so he's trying to
avoid all the counter play by vessel in
is magnus right now
um magnus actually has a small time
deficit
so best one still has his opportunities
here but
it looks very strong
you just have to keep an eyeball over
the pawn breakthrough a5 followed by b6
rook d5
not a big fan of that i think i might
have thrown out h5
yeah well h5 did come
so uh magnus is supposed to be three
years ago three and king g2 improving
the position of his king
well here a big question is rook c5
again uh black has to get in
concrete play is we've got a few more
moves in after king g2 and h4 and g4
king g2
h4 g4 chat yeah or you might want to
update the board um because we can't
we're continuing to get a lot of moves
they're they're moving oh yeah yeah you
got it yeah and now there was that big
threat of queen g3 check
uh i'm not sure i like the way magnus is
doing this but again he's he's he's
playing for this a5 whether this uh g3
and h34 thing actually is safe in his
gang or made it more dangerous i think
he made it more dangerous he fumbled it
a little bit he's definitely because
queen
yeah queen d3 is huge
now now he's got rook a2
oh pardon me there's knight before uh
okay two once played no night before way
before
shaking his head
another night fork oh my goodness the
one even yasser saw that yeah
well thank you thank you so
very frustrated with himself he had rook
f2 in the final position yes playing on
down
the in
that's a nice idea so the idea is that
it's king f2 there's queen d2 check and
then if queen f2 there's queen e4 shaq
no not resignable at all the final
position by the way so no i agree that
was a very premature resignation
though
let's take a look at fabiano's game
because it's going fast and furious too
and fabiano is white against wesley so
the all-american battle maurice
mentioned that being down a minute on
the clock is like being down a piece but
the bad news for fobby is he's also down
some material it looks like there's two
queens on the board
um and so it's a queen and a bishop for
for so
um if you can pull up the game but we
also have it on the big screen here i
see and you see that uh wesley's got um
an extra bishop but um
bishop for two pawns but a pretty bad
pawn structure so it's hard to
to push this comfortably yes it is but
wesley's also got a big time edge um
carolina did gain some time by pulling
in a bunch of quick checks that is the
thing about the increment if you have a
lot of checks you can start building up
your time quite a lot huh yeah
and what do you think the chances are
here eric for i think it's uh close to
uh
maybe uh 50 50.
i think it's yeah
very close to a draw because
unfortunately black's bishop is simply
not that effective against the structure
and you see the players moving back and
forth to make weaknesses or provoke
weaknesses yeah because you can't target
any of the pawns and now wesley i'm
actually equalizing the time trying to
figure out a way to break through or
come up with a plan
um unfortunately for wesley it's a lot
easier for her fobby to play and also
very easy for him to gain time on the
claw exactly he can always just throw in
some checks
yes
it might be a three-time repetition
by the way they won't be they won't know
how to claim it uh
yeah that is true
yeah and there they go we have a draw on
that game that's a big result
because um that uh
the kind of patience
and now we're moving over to the
knockout more game and not the more in
trouble again that's the blitz legend in
trouble but
probably he can hold this one
upon down
yeah i mean glad
well kramek always up upon him
what is he not up upon i must say he's
been beating hikaru a lot uh recently in
his uh these games he seems to be a
tough opponent
but unfortunately there's just not
there's nothing you have to play f3 at
some point
and the players have agreed to address
another draw and that means there's only
one decisive game in this round magnus
carlsen's making that's that's big team
agnes uh yash and i both predicted him
let's remind everyone about that so as
long as hikaru keeps it up like this
it's going to be comfortable you're
always on my coattails always
pick the world champion you can't lose
money from that well i would pick naca
normally but he hasn't shown great uh
great form
let's go to lumen and get some insights
yeah sorry they're not ready for us yet
but uh
with that result we end up uh two-point
lead for magnus because he was one and a
half points ahead last round
everybody else drew
and uh we've got thoughts from alejandro
maurice and luffin
well absolutely big result already in
this second game second round of the day
magnus carlson winning a game that
actually visits
didn't even have to resign he just
resigned in disgust because he saw his
pieces getting forked but he had this
move rook f2 and that would have
continued the game instead he just
gifted this point to magnus of course
magnus doesn't need any gifts he would
have still had an edge but still vasily
just looks completely
rattled right now well he just
completely missed night before and it
was more of the shock of the move that
you know you don't see more resources
you're just like okay i blunder
something let's resign but of course
there was that resource in the position
that still kept the game alive maybe
carlson would have won anyway nobody can
say that for sure he still would have
had an edge the game was very strange in
the fact that carlson was completely
winning at the palace actually outplayed
the world champion let's pull it up
actually in this position just for a
moment because that finish i think most
of our viewers didn't get a chance to
really take a deep look at it right at
this moment he resigned with this move
rook f2 was possible of course king f2
runs into the simple check on d2 having
the real concept grabbing that piece and
if
and so that means you have to play queen
takes and suddenly that knight is
dropping on the other side of course
he's up in exchange
somehow he's gonna have to push his pawn
forward and this b-pawn will be weak
this king is always weak this is a
technical position it's not just simply
lost and for him
i would say it's even closer to a draw
than it is to win especially in blitz
especially in blitz and he had decent
time on the clock he just gave the point
away basically unfortunate for the rest
of the field fortunate for magnus
certainly yeah another disappointing
result for one of the players was
probably the game between wesley so and
fabiano carono this is a game that's
hard to win in blitz and i think that
wesley was just unable to really put
pressure he had a really nice
combination starting with 31 here
uh after bishop f3 we can see that
westing has a lot of pressure because of
this pass pawn on a3 or potentially
passport on a3 which allows this queen
to be cemented on the b2 square and he
took the opportunity to take on b3
take on b3 and now maybe corona was
simply expecting a trade of queens the
pawn pushes forward and when it promotes
to just get an equal bishop end game
because the rook's gonna just take it
off the board right so no problems but
actually wesley was very patient and
very smart about this he played queen
takes b3 sensing that there was no good
play even though white has a full extra
rook for a couple of moves there is no
way to prevent a2 to a1 and actually
this extra material
kept up for a while if we go on just
quickly going through the moves you see
that here still wesley is not converting
the rook he wants to keep the pressure
up and a very good practical decision i
think by fabiano to return some of the
material play bishop takes e6 get that
king exposed
he still wound up in a probably lost end
game but between the amount of checks
the difficulty to protect the king and
the low amount of time that wesley had
left it was enough for vienna to salvage
the draw it's hard to calculate all
those checks in blitz actually hardened
classical chess even so to do it in
blitz practically impossible if they go
on your intuition and you certainly
don't want to hang some kind of fork or
skewer and so wesley was only able to
draw another important game was anand's
draw he was able to show comfortably
that he could handle that position geary
not putting too much pressure on him
with the white pieces we actually had an
unusual case of three opposite color
bishop end games today we had this one
that we just saw uh i'm not held
comfortably against geary despite being
down a uh pond and we also had the game
between mvl and aronian which was
actually kind of exciting spanish but at
the end aronian was able to hold without
any difficulties if anything with the
black pieces he was the one pushing for
a win so everyone wanted to start off
quite quickly everyone who was chasing
magnus but it turns out it's magnus with
that somewhat of a gift in that last
game to paulo just resigning in a pretty
equal-ish position and maybe slightly
worse magnus is now a full two points
ahead of the field that's a pretty
dominant number somebody's going to have
to knock this guy off if anyone's going
to have a chance to win the tournament
otherwise it's going to be the king of
norway magnus carlson who will run away
with this competition
thank you guys and there we have our
standings jen that's right magnus
crossing the massive two-point lead now
um big distance he's putting himself
between
fields yeah but wesley so and we
remember magnus doesn't have grand prix
points since he's not playing in the
sink field in london so wesley so lavon
irony and vichy anand
they're looking for the grand chess tour
points and collecting as many as they
can
indeed and to try to
knock magnus down
and uh crack this tournament wide open
will it happen we'll be right back after
the break to find out
[Music]
so
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the grand chester and move-in we've
got magnus carlson with a two-point lead
over the field but it's a big round
because he plays vichyanan who is one of
the players who can open up this
competition if he beats magnets exactly
and somebody uh has to stop magnus but
uh we opened the show talking about
streaks and blitz guy i'm looking out is
vessel and topolof he started with two
blocks he lost both of those
and he helped magnus by resigning
prematurely
yes that's not something you see often
but on the other hand work takes up too
um if you don't see it of course you're
gonna resign exactly so just a lesson to
you guys at home look for captures and
chats before you resign
because those are the types of things
that you might have a blind spot for for
sure and the fight per second
would get intense
if vishy could pull off a victory in
this the third game against magnus well
i think that if vichy pulls off a win
and the the fighter first opens back up
yeah yeah that's true i mean that gives
a magnet that would give magnus only a
point potentially ahead of the field
which is not a big margin especially
when it comes to blitz where you don't
see as many draws
carl hasn't found his form jennifer he
just he seems to be flip-flopping a bit
can you explain why paris was such a
great result
in this letdown i think that
nakamura is uncharacteristically tired i
mean that's the only explanation i can
come up with because it is quite unusual
i don't think it's overconfidence and
there you go
and we um go to leuven for a quick
comment from alejandro maurice
yes i said that like best in europe well
alejandra is down to playing hall but i
was in the player's room and the body
language difference is so interesting
anand was pensive thoughtful clearly a
bit more agitated as he knows he knows
he has to focus on this game on the
other hand magnus was lucy goosey all
smiles completely relaxed i mean you
think he was just hanging out with the
boys playing blitz as opposed to trying
to win the grand chess tour here in
leuven so if body language says anything
magnus is feeling pretty good going into
this game
some of those photos of magnus in his
first world championship where he's like
spread out over
the chair he looks like the california
boy as you said exactly but i remember
the swimming pool uh
getting getting dunked at the end of
that match as he he pulled off a woman
in chennai very iconic photograph indeed
um and let's take a look and see what
opening we've got here it looks like
another ray lopez no i'm sorry joko
piano yeah italian game um with a closed
a closed center and
that's what
won a really nice game in this variation
against geary and yesterday's blitz so i
like this choice and we'll see um
well vishy one of the most experienced
players in this line well everybody's
playing e4 e5 defenses and magnus seems
perfectly content after all he's the one
with the two-point lead as we see it on
our board and we're keeping an eye on
the players i just love the staging of
this leuven event i can't tell you your
next move has really put on a fantastic
tournament here in belgium indeed the
playing hall is just so beautiful and
it's great to see so many spectators i
mean especially on the weekend but even
on a monday well it's
so unusual for a tournament to end on a
monday i had to check the tournament
calendar like three or four times to
make sure i believed that monday was the
final day but indeed it is
and so here in this position we see um
play that's right uh magnus had just
played the move a5 i like a5 you know
you you
challenge for the dark squares but
magnus is treating the position
differently than uh the other players no
bishop b6 yet no yeah
other ideas we've seen sometimes is
knight g6 h8
knight g6 h6 rookie 8 c6 d5 would be
kind of standard there
we do see the move knight g6 we did see
knight g6 after all
okay well uh
at some point
we need to see this break d3 d4 we just
have to protect the spawn on e4
in order to get that move in so queen c2
strikes me as the most natural move in
the position
i think that she did something else
though i'd
again a very slow play well magnus
rarely gets outplayed in these sorts of
positions it's usually concrete problems
that he might struggle with some you
know active defense that he needs to
find because just slow playing these
positions is totally suitable
for his style and he has a great
understanding in the spanish like one of
the best players ever in in this opening
so bishop b3 again
i
just to go back just to this moment
after the move knight g6 oops uh i was
going to say queen c2 i think would have
been met by c6 with his own idea for
black of getting in d6
d5 and that
move c6 clearly is preparing that error
what's white's advantage here i mean
you've got the dark square bishops off
you have no structural defects there's
black you got a5 for a4 i
i don't i don't see the pole for white
compared to a normal spanish where you
have more pieces on the board here
magnus is happy to trade off
you know the bishops and and operate
like this but he's got
a symmetrical position with
i don't i don't see anything here so he
has to be very happy absolutely i agree
completely we've just seen two
retreating type of moves uh bishop c4 to
b3 to c2 finally we do see the move d3
d4 i wasn't sure
why
uh the move rookie 8 was played i
thought d d6 d5 was compelling and
strong rookie 8 allows this move d4
because in case of a capture there's
this nice queen takes d4
and
fortified it re-fortifying the pawn not
evil well i think magnus wanted vishy to
play d4 we've been seeing him uh allow
opponents to uh attack and uh open
position up and give some counter play
vichy just took on e5
uh i'm
certainly missing something in this
position
black should be very happy absolutely
yeah we don't normally want to take one
maybe on the better side of this the
pawn is on e4 for for white e4 and a4 on
light square is the same color
as the bishops
i think this is more now comfortable
equality for magnus and he can start
looking to push soon if fishy plays uh
pensively such as the way nakamura
played yesterday against magnus
yes and
a change of plan
vishy altered
his play he played the move g2 g3
playing against this knight on g6
quickly some moves were played h6 queen
e2 and moving as rook again from e1 to
d1
and
now
the only thing i see is either you want
to establish the knight on f5 or c4
you'd rather have the light square
bishops off b two b4 b2b for what if you
uh take uh just take on d1 play
brookdale he played man f8 it looks like
is that what i'm seeing yeah it looks
like knight f8 indeed i
move as well because again this move g3
really did corral the knight so on the
night looking for
brighter pastures
um
and
if this
this is
everywhere to play b4 b5 by the way then
the c5 square becomes a very compelling
uh outpost so knight c4 by vision well
now
and now maybe bishop g4 do you play it
right yes right away this is a this is a
great variation because now if you play
knight e3 i'm just going to play bishop
h5 and keep the pin on and it's very
unpleasant because then 96 is coming in
jumping to that d4 square this position
is really turning uh
in favor of magnus yeah exciting which
was expected like 10 moves ago the way
anand played uh well there's one trick
in the position i see eric how about
rook takes d8 rook takes da h3
uh because the pawn on e5 would be
hanging in this case well what if i just
take and queen f3 and 96. well we're
taking a queen takes the eight by magnus
instead
yeah so otherwise i'll take rook d8 h3 i
take on f3 and play knight e6 knight d4
agreed and then i just yeah
agreed uh but i was thinking uh this pen
bishop g4 really is a very annoying one
and and now that she's um followed it up
with rook d1 and uh quick queenie queen
it's like a quick queen e7 27 makes
sense i mean if you play b5
but 96 is is going to be nasty or if you
play b5 you might put that knight to c5
but again uh vichy
in some trouble here that's right so you
can play 96 anyway because after knight
e5 e5 is hanging as the knight c4 takes
e5 so uh
there's still 94 in those lines but
after rook b1 wouldn't be supposed to
especially after rook b1 i wouldn't be
surprised to see bishop f3 96 here
so if you play 96 right away which
actually happened now 95 there's no 95
94 queen 23 and
i'm not sure well you can take
everything magnus shouldn't have done
this quite quite frankly you can't play
with d8 because there's just knight g4
huh yes um
yeah
so knight f3 knight f3 94 is
okay
yeah i think magnus let his advantage
slip so i totally did he totally did i
think if you take on f3 cement that
night on d4 it has to be a good night
against the inferior bishop but so now
he's gonna have to acquiesce just to
knight f3 knight of three and knight
takes e4 let me just flip back and forth
on my board for a second sorry about
that guys he did play 95 by the way i'm
very surprised uh by this uh magnus
definitely uh
letting some opportunity slip by now his
body language actually you see that he's
kind of grimacing a little bit here not
happy with the last couple moves after
gaining an advantage with black slightly
he doesn't have uh
he doesn't have a bushy out clock
clock
but um a lot of times one and a half
minute
to two yeah it's so funny how like when
they think for 10 seconds they often
think for 30 seconds
and they either play instantly or they
think for like 20 30 seconds you see
that a lot at this level absolutely
because there's no point of like the
in-betweener where you just end up
playing the instinctual move anyway you
might as well think and make a better
decision or just play instantly
yeah
now how should magnus continue i don't
see anything better
than knight f3 knight f394
and probably that will be uh a draw
and he has played knight f3 knight f3
and queen takes e4 he decided
uh
regaining his pawn
let me just put those moves on my board
knight f3 knight f3 queen takes e4 we've
seen on the webcam we see an exchange of
wings queen takes e4 knight takes e4
and
well
rook b3 just keeping that knight out of
the c3 square and the knight dropped
back to f6
yeah well right now if you're west to
seoul you're uh levon oroni and you
pretty much have to win they both have
white they're both playing
guys in the lower half uh so uh
because the draw is still okay for
magnus it's really more of a case uh
they need to start bridging the distance
indeed and by the way guys again i'm
just looking at this position i'm still
liking magnus's chances after the move
king g2 as expected there's a smooth
bishop
e6 and that's very annoying because now
so what if i play rookie 3 rookie 3 and
after bishop d5 i take on e8 i play g4
king g3 rookie three i'll be happy to uh
injure your pawns rook takes e3 f takes
e3
i'm looking at a different position
though sorry king g2 uh i thought oh
bishop v6 was played on the board
and bishop d5 was played
uh king f1 nightmare quickly went to g4
and magnus up upon uppercut yeah you're
gonna have three because of knight h
and just uh
wow you can throw in bishop e2 that
might be
that's what he's thinking about yeah and
i think he did actually no he didn't it
went bishop takes jesus i think that
is worse on f1 though yes so
king g2 and magnus up upon king f8
so definitely the first uh
part of today has gone in magnus's favor
and we'll see if he can do the job in
this game and really get a commanding
lead here in the tournament um carlson
offering a trade of rooks here something
that can't be avoided and now after
rooks that's right
black's king unfortunately is too close
the very highly desirable b6 by
white is off
and now just simply b6 and i think this
is just dead one bishop ending for
madness right because he's just going to
throw that one on b5 exactly this is too
easy now
uh
bishop before you just played b6 one's
going down wow
another game magnus
taking advantage of every opportunity
being presented and what other games are
going on jeff well we've got uh wesley
so playing against aneesh giri but the
game that's still pretty
um tight is the game between our ronyon
and look at them blitz yeah they are
blitzing indeed fury
was so agreed to a draw
it's actually lavone ironian versus
vladimir kramnik that's right and uh
has these extra pawns
um but are they all all going to come
off the board yeah aronia needs to
somehow
um try something here otherwise the king
is too far away
if rookie iii king f4 and uh you don't
have any way to um queen that pawn yeah
just rook uh e8 then bring the king
to uh exactly so this game is going to
beat her out
so it's a draw agreed any other games
any other games they're all over
they're all over
made a draw with nbl
oh nakamura won against fabiano
so he actually has an even score today
now
and
magnus has extended his lead by another
half point because he has the closest
competitors have only drawn their games
so
two and a half point lead with six
rounds together in the previous round he
was the only decisive win is that the
same thing
for this round as well no the nakamura
one as well exactly
nakamura won but nakamura essentially
out of the competition and
um eric uh what do you make of this is
the magnus wrapping this up magnus is
wrapping up and other people are taking
too many draws not
me either
i mean there are there are uh tour
points at risk here but it'd be nice to
see some more risk uh for example even
in this position between wesley son and
ishkiri if wesley really i mean he's
saying magnus win maybe thought i can't
catch him because he could still play on
here there's still ways i mean you could
be sure maybe magnus or hikaru would
play this position on so right now i
think people are are getting pretty
afraid of magnus and he's it's up to him
to just close this out
very good uh he's looking good as our
world champion
that's right the world champion are
really showing his skills despite having
a pretty terrible first day
and we do have maurice ashley with the
world champion
we are with the number one player on the
planet magnus carlson after two decisive
games magnus both games your opponents
decided to stop when okay maybe they
were worse in the game the last game
basilan could have sacred f2 this one
you're clearly winning but maybe you
should have played a couple more moves
are you you seem like you're pretty much
hypnotizing them right now uh well i i
think bishop was very short on time
as well um
and uh there really aren't many chances
to save the game so
two and a half point lead is pretty good
at this stage
yeah it's two and a half now that's
that's nice
you seem relaxed going into the game
just overall are you feeling
like the worst is behind you the
blunder from the first day of rapids is
long gone and now you're in control well
the second game today helped me
a lot and probably it was good also to
have a very complicated game in the
first
first round today i didn't play very
well but
helped me to get into some kind of
rhythm and now yeah in the last game i
was
i was calm and i played uh played better
than i did the runs before well that
word rhythm means a lot in chess
congratulations on your victory and
we'll see if he's going to keep that
rhythm it's looking pretty bad for the
field right now magnus carlson two and a
half points
in clear first place in first place and
in control of the grand chester here in
leuven
thank you maurice and as we go to a
break we're going to have a little
special
a very personal tribute to
victor levovich korchnoy by myself
[Music]
hello everyone and i'd like to speak uh
to a chess legend
victor lovovich korchnoy passed away
from the world of chess the other day
and this legendary figure
was a man
who had such a great effect in my life
for which i will always be grateful
for me
victor was an agent provocateur
he was the type of person that was
always poking you needling you forcing
you to make decisions that would be
uncomfortable perhaps he provokes you to
attack and sacrifice material victor was
the type of player that would walk
through the gobi desert just for one
measly pawn but also at the board you
could feel his intensity he literally
radiated an energy and a
rambunctiousness
every player who ever played against
victor korchnoy knew that they were in a
battle for their very lives
it's remarkable when you think about
what victor did in the world of chess
four times he won the soviet
championship which was considered the
greatest tournament in the world
three times essentially he fought for
the world championship and always came
up second best
think of all of the players that he
faced that prevented him from becoming
world champion
michael tall
tigran petrossian boris baskey
bobby fischer
anatoly karpov and finally gary kasparov
in 1976 he defected from the soviet
union a very courageous decision one of
the first players to leave the soviet
union and seek asylum
in 1980 i was invited by victor korchnoy
to be his second
in the 1980-81 world championship
candidate cycle and world championship
matches
and we struck a friendship that lasted
all of our lives and i came in march of
1980 to his home in zurich
and he picked me up from the airport i
was so tired
and we were saying our final good nights
and the both of us were walking into the
guest room i said victor where are you
sleeping says well i'm going to sleep in
the guest room you sleep in the master
bedroom i said no way this is your home
that's not happening i'm sleeping in the
guest room we went back and forth for
some time and then victor said to me
i have a confession i said what's that
he says well in the master bedroom it's
a very very firm mattress because i have
a bad back and the doctor recommends it
when
when i'm sleeping
in the apartment alone i always sleep in
the guest room i said okay in that case
i will he closes the door and as he's
closing the door the last thing he says
to me is
i hope you're not nervous
over the course of the next two weeks
victor and i got to know each other very
very well it became very clear to me
that victor had a high regard for his
person he saw himself as a huge threat
through the soviet world chess
championship title a title that was
politically so crucial to the soviet
state
in victor's mind he was 100 convinced of
this he was going to be assassinated
it's an absolute
and then i began to understand what
victor meant if the assassination was
going to take place
the assassin wouldn't shoot the guy in
the guest room he'd shoot the guy in the
master bedroom and then i became nervous
um
so many stories of victor courtney some
of the ones i like best
is we're in europe of course in many
languages especially the swipes of
deutsche or swiss german was being
spoken
victor went out of his way to ensure
that every time somebody spoke in a
dinner conversation
or
made statements he would always
translate always translate to keep me
appraised of what was going on
his reaching out
was so
endearing
he was very very loyal to people who
were loyal to him
he made me at all times feel as part of
his family there were so many wonderful
stories that i have about victor that at
this moment i would like to really send
a heartfelt message out to petra
victor's wife of 30 years
i know her loss is so great and i also
want to say to her petra leverwick what
a wonderful person she has been to
me
and i thank her so profusely for
everything she's ever done
for me
thank you victor
thank you petra
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the grand chess tour our world
champion looks like he may just run away
with this thing but it is split so
anything can happen yeah but he's really
putting a signature mark on this event
he has his second black running
having just defeated vishyanan
and that will be our marquee game for
this round right i mean enviou an
excellent blitz player we saw him take
down
um we saw him take down hero nakamura
earlier in this the first round of the
split exactly so this will be a big test
and eric do you think magnus is going to
string another one together
uh nbl's certainly one of the players in
the field who does over push it takes as
much risk as possible so this game is
very likely to be decisive one way or
another magnus is looking for revenge
for the loss yesterday though so i think
manus will string another another game
here
all right and we see the players as they
get ready for action
and that
i was going to say maxine needing
needing a win to stop this runaway
magnus train
and look at them go between
vladimir kramnik and vessel and topalov
maxine needs to create an imbalanced
sharp position i mean he's generally
just not going to help play magnus from
a slow maneuvering sort of uh
setup although
india and now this is a very sharp
variation that white goes e4 i believe
yes
well that's typical for him avoiding the
sharpest theoretical line
exactly but
okay why suppose
got some nice space with his big center
palms
on e4 c4 and d4 it's the kind of thing
like if black organ will play this
opening every game a lot more people
would play d4
exactly right well magnus switched it up
with a stone wall to stop that pattern
exactly but he had played the bogo
indian yesterday yesterday
and then we saw bishop d2 instead of 92.
and he equalized very very comfortably
and uh even
uh went on to win that's right so uh we
see him play so he might have some
special ideas here we see him play c5 d5
as we know from magnus it's not all
about getting the best opening possible
it's about making your opponents
uncomfortable especially in blitz
and he's played 97 in mbl quickly
castling
but if it's going to be a benoni type of
game
with e 6 takes d5 well this bishop
really looks strange on e7 so he's
uh brought it back to a czech binoni uh
position with this dark squared bishop
on e7 not g7 magnus wants my 98 g6 maybe
knight g7 that sort of you know spanish
sort of structure but for sure this is
supposed to be better for white giving
up all the space is
not the best although
you have to be quite precise if you're
playing white well two things uh
catch my eye about this specific
position is that the knight on d2 is
passively positioned normally it's much
better on the c3 square and
the second thing is white has already
committed his king to the king side a5
mixing things up um
i think that indicates you want to play
a4 maybe uh a5 yourself as white and uh
try to put pressure on v7 but
it's certainly not the positional move
but
well basically uh that's exactly what uh
nbl's doing mvl was committed uh to
playing the move a4 and now we're
expecting
maneuver you mentioned
uh eric
trying to bring that knight to g7 he
chose knight h5 as the starting move
which i think is fine and uh he has
provoked g3 which is a useful
provocation because it means that in the
future we may very well see a bishop h3
uh bishop c8 h3 landing on the board
knight e1 you know what maxine vs magnus
doesn't that sound like a superhero
battle it does doesn't it
watch out marvel comics doesn't even
sound real knight g7
knight g2 as both players are preparing
f5 f4 might be uh might be on the board
absolutely well i think f5 is is a kind
of a key move that black absolutely has
to get in but he didn't play uh magnus
slow played it with
knight f
six magnus slow playing what uh what a
surprise yeah and again this knight on
uh b3 is not making a very big
impression
when the knight is on c3 it often
sticks itself on the b5 square
attacking d6 and c7 squares
f2 f3
i'm not sure i really like this way for
maxine
bishop h3 rook f2
i actually like this move very much
because rook f2 is eyeballing the
opportunity to come over here to b2 and
pressure this pawn on b7
magnus is preparing f5
so magnus first wanted to develop this
bishop
to h3b4 getting it in f5 and knight e3
well again a very strange play by white
i'm i'm not a big fan of this position
for white i like the move f7 f5 and
given a choice i could play black he's
gotten in bishop f1 trading on the f1
square bishop f1 queen f1
and now uh
the big move here if i'm black is i
really want to play the move f5 or
bishop
g bishop e7 to g5 bishop bishop g5
that's what magnus started with
bishop g5 played in the game and he's
still going to try to play the move out
for him
exactly
all right
and still again this knight on b3 just
really
loose well it just does nothing it's
it's
it's just on a very bad circuit um
easier play definitely for the world
championships
there's been a capture on f5 and magnus
decided to create this imbalance after
um bishop takes e3 bishop takes e3 takes
f5i nice square nice
blocks position yeah it just
he's just
magnus and cruise control he just looks
so
he plays so easily and well seen another
trade with knight d4 knight take c4 c
takes d4 now the c5 square is super
juicy
i mean that is the minor piece i like
magnus played bishop before
preventing that idea or rather if it
happens he's going to snap it right but
okay
black has a protected and can i play
queen b6 here how's that going i guess
you have rook b2 so it's a bit of going
no i like queen beasts b6 has been
played absolutely i like queen b6 very
much in fact
um because the point is if you play rook
b2 i can always play knight c5 here in a
pin
and um well also rook
be you got to be careful that there
might be an e5 e4 exactly and d3 check
is always in the air too right now it
doesn't do much but it could do
something later absolutely
a
very very s uh concretely
um
scary position for for accidents
but he has played work b too so now
fighting e4 i'm really surprised e4
looks like a really big shot but instead
of magnus started with d3 check but
maybe he's going to follow it up with b4
well h3 is annoying because of queen uh
f2 there's rook
and if you are that's a good one if
you're forced to move your king queen d4
looks like a very big one that's what
magnus started with you've just played
queen d4 here and then storing those
reps that looks
horrifying horrifying you just kind of
you gotta play
um
well he's played rook b3 now rook f3
pretty
strong shot in this box but magnus just
played e4 works as well i mean this this
is just by the way c4 is now hanging oh
this is a the total disaster for mdl yes
lovely game by magnus and an opening
that looks so passive at first yeah but
he just he just easily outplayed his
these are top guys i mean the world
champion just seems to be in a zone of
his own when he plays his best chess
he's imperial this is what's fantastic
best game though most convincing i mean
just absolutely crushing it i mean to be
fair um edl perhaps a bit tired because
he's not really showing his stuff we've
seen him play some really fantastic
games in the grand chester this one he
bishop um
probably just queen c4
b7 that's on the board c3 then rook f3
just turn everything off and take on f3
wow and you've got those coupons and we
know how valuable those are um the two
pawns both headed to this well
soon they're going to be both on the six
right exactly and they say that's worth
a rock
marie said it's uh it's worth a minute
it could be worth a piece well how many
um
just wins on the spot exactly instead of
even taking on f3 just e3 e2 of rook c1
just e2 after exactly he does delete it
and he's just played probably
resignation soon
absolutely wow talk about getting your
doors blown and just take a look
visually at this position
you know magnus
a terror and what i i what i do admire
is that he's been playing such combative
openings you know sometimes people um
say that magnus likes to play some
really quiet lines and try to get a
small edge but with black he's been
going for it in the blitz and the rapids
he's putting the pressure on his face
stonewall dutchess bogo indians nimzo
indians
really really uh impressive
play uh in
this event well there's lots of less
ambitious lines of play against the bogo
so of course maxim also getting the
credit for playing such
an ambitious line but um
i don't know
indeed well we'd see this move rook be
one uh
on it
you know he's hoping that by doubling
his rooks on the seventh but with this
queen
defending the g uh seven square i think
this is really helpless
very fine move by the way rook v6 by
magnus you can't capture on b6 the e2
pawn just goes home
um
this is such a beautiful move just
showing how welch kind of play the
combination of attack and defense and
jazz beautiful just
awesome when you just
you just have to
catch your breath and say awesome this
is the kind of position that it must be
fun
i mean
magnus is just like
enjoying himself now isn't he rook b6 e2
and there you have it the resignation
because he is going to get two queens
big news wesley so has also won how did
he win in this position did he win is
that for sure yes
why is this winning
i don't know it doesn't draw on my board
though oh yeah that's going to be draw i
mean it looks like a drop because uh you
can't uh tops the bishop
okay so leslie
has drawn the game in fact
all right let's just see
and we have the nakamura game still
underway
this bishop
this is going to be a tough one to win
uh white's king doesn't really have very
good entry squares you're going to have
to take a very long
route
fabiano against lavon i think that's
another name that we have on our board
by the way that that is fabiano fabiano
is very sharp right now okay let's turn
yeah let's move over to that i agree
this one is a
looking like a beautiful bishop there
for fabi
i mean that's got to be the we we saw a
game where the knight was the better
minor piece and exactly the opposite
here and he's just acted in exchange on
d5 after queen takes d5 fabi
um intuiting that uh his his bishop's
just going to be so powerful and we're
actually going to be able to take on g7
i think this is just absolutely over
queen g fight check is huge
g7 with the pawn
and now uh queen c6 um i mean black has
a lot of counter play on the light
squares here uh there's a few more
convincing lines because
uh queen h5 you can just walk to f7 and
as long as the queen on c6 protects the
rook on e8 there's no clear breakthrough
we saw this move bishop e5 and
and we're making another queen that's
the second two queen game what's going
on
well it's the round for the ladies isn't
it uh with this movie
the bishop e5 the last game on um on our
dock is
onishgiri versus nakamura is nakamura
still in trouble let's take a look is
the kramnik uh yeah there's that game
and
yeah
kramek topolov i think might be ongoing
and this is this bishop ending i was
about to say that black looks like
white's making progress maybe getting
liking the g7 yeah white had to uh do
this uh long route with this king over
to g7 and you're absolutely right indeed
this could create some zuzwan situations
because the king can't leave e7 if the
pawn goes on f6 that's a goner so the
pawn on a3 it's on the right color do
you try to play d5 d6 absolutely
absolutely to break out the fortress so
we'll trade the d-pawn for the f6 pawn
and then black's gonna have to sacrifice
but the question is whether he can get
his king to win the a
a pawn in time so d6 king d6 king of six
i think
looks very close to a draw agreed just
because the king is too far out for
white to protect the a3 pawn so king d6
king f6 king c5 king g7 bishop f5 bishop
f5
and king c4 so we have had seen we've
seen the trade of pawns
eric and insta
bishop c2
was the move that uh
was played and now king
g5 hmm
i thought he was going to go king g7
with the idea of just pushing that pawn
fast king e5 has been played and now the
bishop moves
and now what happens if bishop f5 bishop
f5 king d4
and i just want to walk to draw i think
that's the draw because i'm going to get
my king
b2 or b3 you can't stop both
he has played it
bishop f5 bishop f5 king d4 and it looks
like
black is in time to trade off the last
pawn
and
claim a draw
so
a big escape i think by hikaru that's
important because ikaro still has the
chance to put together some wins but he
really needs um to at least keep an even
score and this will keep him on even
exactly king city so then he gets a last
um
alaska spurred at the end it will still
be worth something
and we do have nakamura saving the draw
there against anish gary
um well done
indeed
but magnus carlson a runaway train it is
a magnificent
he was he was fantastic in round two
where he swept the rapid chess results
4-0
and he's put together a fantastic run
on let's get impressions from
belgium with maurice and alejandro
well from contenders to pretenders all
the players who were chasing magnus have
not been able to do anything at all
they've all lost at least one game i
think i think they've each lost a game
so far and magnus on the other hand has
won three games in a row he simply
distanced himself from the field and it
looks like it's all over now
with five rounds left
there's got to be an epic collapse for
magnus to actually not win this event
mathematically it's not over but man
magnus looks so consistent so good every
game he's just putting it out there he's
just definitely showing he has the best
chess whereas the others they're seeing
meek in their chest they're not playing
the best they're missing opportunities
and they're just making a huge
difference in in the standings even the
fight for second place doesn't look
convincing the way they're playing right
now the other players and magnus
certainly looking like a star this is
one game wesley soul had versus anand
and this game he had a golden
opportunity to win the game and missed a
very powerful shot he came up with a
brilliant idea but was unable to follow
it up here in this complicated position
and i probably thought he was okay he's
attacking the knight on f3 he sacrificed
a pawn earlier on f5 but he'll get it
back and here so came up with this
excellent idea knight takes g5 which
seems like it blunders a piece but he
saw further ahead
knight takes g3's check so you have to
recapture with the f pawn and then pawn
takes g5 and it seems at the end of the
day white is down a piece but there's
this important point f6 check exploiting
the fact that the king is so weak
bringing in more pieces to the attack
eliminating some of the defenders this
is an awesome move that the rook takes
f6 from texas f6 king takes f6 this was
the key position in which wesley had to
find the killing blow to continue the
attack and take the full point how do
you play the move queen to h5 which is
probably one of the only two candidates
i can think of right now on f7 by the
way yeah the game would have been over
you simply bring the rook over on f1 the
next uh move the bishop must block on f5
at some point but then you add more fuel
to the fire with either knight e3 or g4
let's take a look at some of those
variations the key move everyone would
wonder about his move d5 but of course
here comes his rook and it's just
tremendous attack with the bishop to f5
and now the knight and you can see all
the pieces hovering over that king if
you dare to take this bishop off the
board well here comes the queen as well
and you're just getting tossed uh to the
wolves with all these captures
definitely you can see that none of
these pieces are defending the king it's
going to be crushed by a queen and a
rook it's just simply too much material
attacking this was the golden
opportunity for wesley he still had
other chances further down the game but
they were much much more complicated he
thought he had to go into this opposite
color bishop end game which even though
he was up two pawns he was unable to win
absolutely so it just looks like it's
the madness show right now the other
players will be struggling for second
place now that said
magnus because he's not playing in the
sink field cup or the london chess
classic
not really going to be a contender for
the grand chess tour title so second
place here will matter is almost going
to be like a first place finish so they
want to finish strong these other
players so we'll be taking a look at
more of their games to see who will get
those points as we think about the
future of the grand chess tour thank you
gentlemen and that was a crucial uh
point there for wesley so as we can see
in the standings jennifer
magnus a three-point lead wesley saw in
second and he could have really put his
print on second eddie one against fishy
he missed an opportunity still all of
the grabs for second it appears to me
it's it's crazy how again except for
magnets nobody has a plus score that's
very big right nakamura kramnik aronia
and they only have plus one
right it's really insane and that's why
magnus is so dominant and he's
catapulted to a three-point lead yes um
eric uh your thoughts
it's just an absolute pleasure to watch
magnus in the zone i mean he's not
giving his opponents any chances in
these strategical positions so if this
continues i mean we might just have to
watch some of the other players battle
for second third fourth
yeah
but yeah it's um he's getting the
positions that he excels in and people
are not
able to handle that so it's just magnus
in the zone and
nobody can stop them lovely chess to
watch to watch such great moves being
played so quickly like rook b6 it's fun
it is fun
and we are going to be back for more
from the grand chess tour where magnus
looks like he's running away with it in
just a few minutes
[Music]
um
hmm
[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the grand chess tour and that
beautiful playing hall in leuven
i i'm so impressed by your next moves
tournament this grand chess tour has
just been a magnificent addition to this
tour
and now that we're four rounds into the
blitz we see
magnus carlson is just playing
crushing chess he's in his own yeah and
he's um very hard to match up with in
fact here he is he's playing in vladimir
kramnik he's gonna get another win we'll
find out but we're also gonna be keeping
an eye on nakamura verso the two
american stars nakamura traditionally
the better blitz player but still having
the better tournament so who's your pick
in this event well uh in this game yes
exactly hucaro's having a difficult time
wesley in second place this will be our
game that we follow as we get started
here for this round
and really wesley needs to just to score
in this game
to keep his second place position
and we have a quiet e3 queens gambit
declined
c4 just been played by
uh
ricardo and c5 keeping it's measurable
keeping it symmetrical you can't do that
forever
as many children who learn chess learn
and when it looks like we're about to
see an isolated queen pond position
coming oh no uh
icaru's decided to definitely give the
game a different take and he's played
the move e4 sharper feel all of a sudden
knight c3 you take on d4 play bishop b4
yeah there's been a tr a queen trait
however after takes on d4 queen takes d4
i'm expecting the queen trait i should
say
and then a6 probably seems normal he
takes d4 knight takes d4 bishop b4 is a
little bit more ambitious than simply
what happens if knight a5 uh starting
knight b5 in that variation yeah exactly
and then uh knight a6 but he has played
your move uh eric a7 a6 that is to say
wesley has
now i like the simple move f2 f3 just
fortifying the center and from the
webcam i can see
that was ikaro's choice as well the idea
is to keep this knight on f6 under lock
and key thanks to the structure e4 e5
seems like it might happen here trade
off the dark sword bishops for uh black
would be an achievement because
otherwise
it's a pretty nice structure for for
white bishop c5 bishop e3 knight c6
okay what played quickly
knight c2
dropping back or even castles long
would be my choices as white
well it seems fairly
fairly when i just play oh okay even
knights fairly even yeah yeah
trade of bishops on e3 has been played
and now king e7 and again
um
well there's a
no i don't think it's there's i'm
thinking that there's a little something
something to try for knight c4 to b6 but
i think you have to preface such a
maneuver with a2 a4
not what he calls
one here played rook c1 or
maybe knight a4 we're going to see and
knight b6 yeah knight 849 b6 it's it's a
little bit at least there's
there's some play in the position for
white but there's really not much going
on here after knight b6 with b8
uh
as played
yeah yeah i guess bishop e2 king f2 you
don't want to castles white keep your
king close to the center because
there's not
much
reason to
castle or hide the king
exactly
so again we can easily imagine that
after developing light king f2 bishop e8
bishop e2 knight d7 some pieces are
going to be traded off the chopping
block on the d file as well as the b6
square
looks again very uh
tame
with the exception of magnus i mean he's
just
he's just blowing the field away
everybody seems to be playing it very
tight eric
yeah i agree there's two players though
i wanted to focus on anushkiri
and nakamura they both need they both
had very disappointing blitz events
especially anish in either event he
continues to draw out i don't know how
that's possible uh he could play a
spoiler right now because he has a
dynamic position against levon aronian
with black two bishops uh down upon for
compensation but no matter what position
he's getting anishkiri is finding a way
to draw but hope this game he could
really make a big impact on the
standings and play a spoiler alert he's
got two bishops here got the open g file
has very reasonable compensation in my
mind so i think that might be a game we
might switch to not even just a spoiler
alert eric because um eric those
standings at the bottom are actually
pretty tight if banished wins this game
he could leapfrog over vessel and
topolove he's creeping up on kramnik
there's he's picking up on ricardo as
well you see the stamina it's pretty
important for annie to get out of the
basement by winning in this game you
know just by winning one game he goes up
three places wow potentially potentially
of course some there's some players
would have to lose for that exactly but
he um he goes up a couple places um big
um important for any not to finish in
last because finishing in last with um
you know
minus two or something like that's kind
of unfortunate it's unfortunate but
can't they just throw that result out as
you mentioned so right the difference
between last and second to last might
not have any impact on on grand chest
store standings although rating these
guys care about exactly
um in the game of uh fabiana car pardon
me um the vessel and topolof
fabiano
looks to me like uh fabi's got a really
good position i like what he's done
for this game i can easily imagine
bishop f5 bishop g4 very irritating
moves and fabi's got this great square
on c5 for his knight so i really like uh
what he has done in this game
um let me just uh take a look at that
anish position because that is actually
the more interesting of all the games so
far
um i have this uh situation on the board
rook on g8 making it very very awkward
indeed for lavone to develop these king
side pieces
that's not the only feature of the
position of course
but
that is a key one
yeah that's hard for you to make
exchanges with my taste d4 right i don't
want to really help black get this
bishop to b4 with a check
so
anish gary doing his best
to
create
uh chances for himself
in this
otherwise magnus slightly better against
kramnik but very very raj there uh anand
and viel looking well nbl's ananda story
is up upon but there's rooks and
opposite bishops on the board so
he's pushing right
just flipping back to what we hope would
be a marquee game
between what um karu and wesley
seems very very dry
nothing going on the same feeling wesley
is black playing as hikaru hikaru is
nothing here and yesterday we saw magnus
push this sort of position as black so
i mean starting soon if i'm black i'm
starting to think about g5 here f5 here
and maybe getting a little ambitious uh
if if necessary we certainly saw magnus
squeeze this sort of structure yesterday
so and almost went almost when but this
is certainly not more preferable for
white at this point
on the contrary i definitely agree with
you that after moves like b5 which
happened and e5 uh
cementing this knight and at the same
time this bishop on f1 looks very poorly
on that square and we see b5 h45 blacks
for choice i think they're better minor
pieces yeah black is simply for choice
picaro
getting nothing with d4 i mean maybe he
has to play e4 again or c4 because he is
getting cement these these
symmetrical positions that he clearly
isn't that comfortable in well let's
stay with this game then and see if
leslie can do his best magnus impression
he
he does have a great smile like magnets
and a very good move bishop uh
to e6 just uh keeping
this bishop on f1 passive uh an exciting
thing in the magnus game he might be
pulling a nigel short and king walking
uh put it on your board yeah i got my
board over here magnus carlson as white
here walking along the dark squares and
in a perfect world i'm gonna play king
g5 king h6 there's that famous game
short against him on um black is going
to have to play king h7 at some point
but this is a good end game if this this
king is better than black's king you
trade off the queens the rook and king
might penetrate so magnus is pushing
without any risk here and that king is
getting dangerously close that's right i
mean can we in some variations we can
also consider putting the king all the
way on f6 f6 exactly
seven i mean that's just a glorious so
did that with how similar was that to
the short king walk when did you eat
him on game yeah yeah but he went to h6
to set up a big checkmating uh pattern
it's funny if you do it if you do it
right here i just want to show if you
play too quickly and you play king g5
there would be this nice funny
self mate oh dear queen here love
what a beautiful line eric but instead
they've traded queens but that means
magnus should be transitioning to a
winning end game yeah if he plays this
properly this king is playing it well
this is just very useful you can't play
f6 because of king e6 but otherwise i'm
gonna play f4 f5 create some weaknesses
here or maybe play rook c8 pretty soon
but this looks like uh
almost a losing end game
yeah domination gorgeous beautiful just
because it's solely because of the king
position gotta love it so i love your
other variation though perhaps kramnik
should have uh stand at the heat a
little bit and tried to go for some
tricks such as that rather than just go
straight into this uh very unpleasant
yeah well it looks like song actually i
mean what is black going to do for me
and nakamura in big trouble right now
okay we'll flip back to that game and
again a huge game for wesley so
and his ambitions
uh to take second place and we see some
of this body language by nakamura even
though he has a minute left on the clock
playing like he has 10 seconds and
usually he does that when he's not happy
with his position exactly because it's
it's just a typical uh blitz thing
figuring that his best chance now is to
kind of intimidate his opponent and at
least keep a hand on the clock exactly
but this looks very very good for for
for black
thanks to this uh dominating knight on
the tv on the f3 square that is a really
nice night now
um
wesley's gonna have to somehow start
advancing his pawns yeah in order to
increase his advantage perhaps starting
with just g6 and and then f5 and he's
done that g6 h5 played very very quickly
by nikaru okay here you go f5 there's a
trade on g6 and
after rook takes g6 and e4 and the
problem is you can't even sack because
knight d2 is coming in precisely and
this has happened by the way
this is this is very close to over
wow
[Music]
d4 i believe
knight before and our pawn is a
hesitation
and
no capturing
on g6 instead
knight d4 94
automatic then e4
then push those pawns down it's who's
quicker here the problem with knight d4
is now if you take on g6 e4 just traps
the bishop right a quick uh repetition
by wesley to gain some time on the clock
you do get two second increments 41
seconds to 45 seconds pretty thin he's
probably gaining a second with each move
but okay
take what you can get against knockout
exactly and so we're expecting the move
knight d4
followed quickly by e4 he played e4
right away e4 interesting so now bishop
takes b5 as possible
as his rook takes b5 as his d6 check so
definitely making things more
complicated the knight before was just
such a solid move king of six maybe the
only move here
d6 jack
he played king e6 that does allow him
king e6 i'll play bishop bishop c4 but
it also allows bishop b5 threatening
bishops i really really don't like the
way he carries uh pardon me that how
wesley has done this and i definitely
think he's uh
put himself at great risk oh yeah that
is also quite strong and now wesley's
going to go for this
for the draw i think uh
i think he's
uh
yes he's got it yeah
so
that's he bailed out but a save by both
players at the end
and has magnus put the big hurt on big
vlad not quite yet vlad gave up i think
three pawns for active counter play uh
now he's playing down two pawns here but
uh
this should be all she wrote right it
should be all she wrote but uh he's
still fighting on here okay he's going
to push that a pawn down the board and
try to get
the d-pawn or something for it
okay so just so that i've got oh sorry
i'm way behind i'm way behind
on f5 g5 and g4 so there's three pawns
but that rook on h4 is not ideal
here we have uh uh my board's not up to
fantastic view somebody's back
i
think i think this is closer to a draw
despite the
two extra pawns
i don't see how magnus is going to
release his rook
that's a very unusual in-game
constellation isn't it absolutely and
he's only got three seconds left and it
drops agreed and withdrawal waving his
hand i think enough and disgust yeah i
mean in a lot of circumstances you would
fight for
that those two second increments don't
build up that quickly enough no they
don't uh eric if we can come to your
board just take us to that magnus
carlson ending when we thought after
the queens had gotten off
that this was like over it is over and
kramnik was forced to play g5 here you
can't move the rook anywhere because of
king d6 you can't play f6 as i mentioned
so after g5 8g5 kramek played h4 here a
lot of moves when
magnus played out four he could have
just played king f5 king g4 picked off a
second pawn while still controlling this
holding foul let's see what happened f4
king g6 this is all still winning by the
way everything was winning rook g8 king
h7 and and now after rook c8
trying to win this bond it's still all
winning
rook c6 rookie seven
and allowing the rook to e2 that's when
things got a little bad was where he
let
vladimir back into the game by letting
him activate it he didn't have to do it
he can always just play rook e8 after
move like here f5 king here
f6 and playing rook uh e7 and rook f7
and always being able to block the one
file which is the e file that would have
that would have done it wow
so a narrow escape by vladimir how does
that affect our uh
because wesley drew we have uh did lavon
how did lavon finally finish with this
game with
anish um let's see it looks like uh that
game
i don't have a result for that game yet
but it looks like uh oh my goodness are
they still playing no i thought that the
no i think it's over we'll check we'll
find that out in in just a second
that was a draw in fact it was a draw
okay so neither player making headway in
that
from that round
and let's go to uh luven with
well now that we know that magnus is
going to win the tournament i mean
an epic collapse is probably even
too small a way of putting what would
have to happen for magnus to not win
this event now the race is really indeed
for second place and as we said second
is almost like first since magnus's
points won't count for the grand chess
tour given that he's not going to play
in the next two big events
and so we get some big results and this
result is a huge one anand defeating
maxim vashila grav who finished third in
paris and he's got some good grandchild
points that he wants to get anand saying
look i've entered the show right now
this is my first event mrs magnus is not
going to count if i can win this against
the rest of you clowns i'm also up there
yeah absolutely and i'm trying to say
that he's still up there this was an
important victory for him he had been a
little bit shaky in the blitz today so
it's important for him to win again he
hadn't won since he beat paulov in the
first round and this was a very
technical win uh you see in this
position that white is uh really just
up a pawn after the trade queen takes uh
here queen takes e3 bishop takes c3 rook
takes e6 but it's a very complicated
technical task opposite color bishops
very active rooks by black a better pawn
structure in the end it's very difficult
to win but not very precisely step by
step out playing maxima sharia graph and
won in an opposite bishop caller in game
yeah that's important again anan looking
to
get all those points
for coming in second but in essence
coming in first place the other two
games were drawn that is wesley seoul's
game where he had a real chance there
and also the game with aronian so those
are the three that are really jostling
for second place slash first place right
now as magnus is just making it look
like okay so what i drew against kramnik
when i should have won
big deal he's definitely going to win
this affair
thank you gentlemen and
let us consider uh from paris how many
uh grand chess tour points and
what's at stake in terms of grand
chester report because remember hikaru
put picked up a bonus from
paris as well
well here are standards right now we see
nakamura climbing up a little bit that's
important because um because he came
first in paris with the 13 points
two more points they come in fifth in
this he could still be leading the tour
you're definitely salvaged and wesley so
who had a very decent result in paris uh
for sure he's looking at it second place
and the potential for
ten points or is it eleven i think
that's ten points right
and so we can take a look actually right
now what we got um for tour points after
paris magnus carlson has ten but he's
not really eligible nakamura with 13
wesley picking up seven so
he picks up seven if he gets 10 that's a
total of 17.
nakamura has to come in at least six to
surpass that um but he has a very good
chance to do that actually
if he finds his blitz form in these last
few games and wins a game or two um he
could uh be first is there anybody else
who's likely to be first i don't think
so
uh it was okay but mbl
he needs to both those players uh need
to string together uh some good results
in these final rounds and i don't even
think so anyway i think it's going to be
very hard oh because they're going to
have to get his they're going to have to
surpass wesley exactly in order yeah
pass wesley they have a chance
and eric your thoughts on uh how this
fourth day of blitz has been going so
far well the last couple of rounds i've
noticed technique is starting to drop
wesley those those guys fighting for
second are gonna have to convert those
those positions that um we're seeing
somehow turn into draws but otherwise uh
you know it's still the same
story as before magnus magnus magnus but
uh
i would like to brag i'll wait a few
rounds until we finally get the
predictions right so i'll keep my out
for the second place mvl aronian uh so
but yeah technique has to improve for
anybody wanting to secure second place
very good and just uh because i've got
you eric at the board did wesley so
uh he i think he blew it very badly with
this move e4 i think it was move 45
had he played what we all expected which
was this move knight d4 yes uh would
that have
secured wesley a win
um i think it would have i always favor
the knights the position is good there
aren't really any real
strong moves for nakamura he probably
would have known him he wouldn't blunder
he would just play an active move
something like a4 try to put up a little
bit of resistance here let's say a4 b4
then a5 and do this sort of pawn race
then we have e4 coming in then d6
it gets a little bit you know tricky
king d8 i think this is winning for
black but it requires a bit of accuracy
a little bit of pressure here moves like
bishop b5 it's it's the only try for
for nakamura so it's not entirely
decisive
but uh certainly forces nakamura to find
only moves to to survive and it doesn't
allow the same kind of play that we saw
during the game thank you very much yeah
because knight d4 i thought that was
just a cruncher but maybe
not as decisive i thought as i thought
maybe against most people i guess not
the more like eric mentioned it would
find whatever play there is
so i can't say totally decisive exactly
yeah especially they're playing a blitz
game one minute one minute left in their
life and i wasn't really too sure about
their times either
yeah they were pretty even like without
amenities and western was trying to like
you say you know you get two seconds but
it takes you a second to
put the moves even if they're
repetitious you gotta figure how long it
takes you to think about like how many
times you're repeating it and um
for it to occur to you to do it
it's a little thin when it's only a two
second increment agreed
yeah yeah
so
we are now uh getting all set for uh
uh
we're gonna get stuff for our long break
so we'll see you guys in about a half
hour
yeah i think dinner break over there or
whatever you want to call it uh reset
break i'm probably magnus wishes they
could jeske playing
yeah
and we are going to be covering the
closing ceremonies after this is all
over with so um get yourself a coffee
guys and get ready for the last four
rounds here
in luven and see who's going to
get second place and if there's a
possibility that magnus will completely
melt down
it's always possible we saw it
[Music]
so
now
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the grand chess tour
from move in belgium here we see a
beautiful shot of the playing hall and
spectators
in this
15th century town hall from belgium
we've got a runaway winner the magnus
train is performing on all cylinders
he's just playing great chess dominating
chess and the big question is who's
going to take second place we have a
marquee match-up going on between wesley
so and lavone aronian as they're getting
set for play and as we can see from our
standings
uh wesley so has a slim half point
margin jennifer what's your take well
yeah it's just uh
it's astounding to see magnus carlsen
perform so well and it's also
outstanding to see that
everybody else is performing okay
nobody's tanking and nobody's soaring
except for madness
and
let's go to belgium
for some comment
well the players are extremely relaxed
we saw them play some casual blitz with
lawrence trent who's always at the
center of some kind of nonsense in this
place but they're very relaxed now it
looks like magnus knows all he has to do
is play well for this round and he
should run away with the tournament and
then we're hearing the bells toll once
again we always hear it in the town
square gives a sort of ominous feel to
the place but we certainly enjoy and
have enjoyed our stay here definitely
the players enjoying a little bit of
time off between rounds 30 minutes was
to break uh pretty much everybody went
outside even though it was raining they
decided hey i want to get some fresh air
some of them got some food a couple
played some blitz matches and well they
know that getting into a tournament
that's this long they can't stay in the
same room all the time they have to
clear their head
all right so we are going to take the
the commentary
this time around there are some
technical difficulties in the studio so
we're going to focus on this game
between wesley soul and levon aronian a
critical game for the standings because
after all wesley is in second place
aronian only a half a point behind him
and this game could mean quite a bit for
the standings in the event and i'm
seeing our board now suddenly what did
you do alejandro you touched i don't
think that's true
that didn't help we're gonna throw it
back to you guys just for a moment while
we fix this board and then we'll get
right to the games i have moves
we actually are getting moves over here
it seems and it's and it's a marshall
uh gambit marshall gambit that we
haven't seen much of in this
it's a favorite of lavonna aronian has a
lot of experience on the black side it's
been a big part of his repertoire
throughout his whole career and let's
just go
i'll do it very quickly the marshall
gambit we've seen a lot of marshall
type of openings here but not a strict
marshal so yes black gives up a
a pawn for this great activity quick
development bishop g4 queen f1 so knight
d2 and let me get caught up with the
players very theoretical line and that's
why you see them playing so quickly and
particularly wesley who's got more time
than we started with
and uh trust me this bishop f4 move as
spectacular as it looks uh i'll bet
dollars to donuts then it's all theory
still at this point
right so you can't take the bishop
that's the assumption you can't take the
bishop presumably because of well
should i it's nice
takes f4 so queen g6 check immediately
there is queen g3 so starting with
knight f4 are now prohibiting queen g3
so that next move if we play queen g6
check we'll be able to play knight e2
right so how would you defend against
that part you have to play like on 94 or
something like that well the problem
with 94 is queen takes f3 exactly and
oops i think that that's all she's wrote
because we're just running 92 almost
checkmating exactly if i go bishop f
bishop takes d5 it's going to be one of
those bishops of opposite color
positions where
thanks to the light squares black has
sufficient compensation either after
queen takes or e takes d5
not much of an extra pawn in that
position so let me just wesley thinking
for over a minute in this position i was
mentioning that he had more time on the
clock than he started with before this
move right now he's absolutely in the
tank so
again bending dollars to whatever kind
of lovely pastries we have over there we
had some good pastries to start the day
that's that's that's right and um it
looks like uh wesley not no longer in
theory um and he has played a move
well it's either queen e2 yes which is
shuttling to the corner right and now
the big question is should black play
rookie eight but he is putting his
pieces into some kind of
awkward pins knight f1 so rookie eight i
still can't play knight e4 i'm dying to
play this move man no i got all my
pieces but you have just rook takes e4
yes that is if you play rookie eight
right yes i was just saying rookie 8
94 what you were mentioning jennifer
rook takes e4 is
oops that's a mistake that's the end of
the day so rookie eight um hasn't been
played yet by lavon though sweet h6 is
an alternative although rookie it seems
okay so eric go ahead take it the
alternative is maybe queen h6 try to
just
be annoying
no i mean it's very
unusual way of pinning a bishop on c1
isn't it
you're never annoying eric
that's his middle name and so after
bishop uh uh
after queen h6 how about bishop takes
defense yeah bishop d5 citizens
b3 and i play rook e8
in this moment and i'll probably want to
play uh
if i trade or bishop d2 no i'll trade on
e3
well i'll play rookie 60 out of 10. so
bishop e3 rookie three rook e3 and then
queen d2
queen d2 queen e6
that's like sufficient queen queen e6 is
the idea that's right uh yes and we
don't have a sufficient um protection
but he's played rookie
he did play also a very tempting and
natural move indeed yeah no rookie 8 was
probably the most natural but queen h6
would have caused definitely caused some
problems as well so after this move rook
e8 eric what do you reckon is the 9 f1
because f1 um knight e4 i don't see
another move uh and a move like bishop
d5 here just uh
uh you can even do queen d5 so it's just
not looking attractive and black can
just get out of this pin on the e file
by playing rookie six so
i think just get out of the way right
knight f1 uh trade pieces off and make
life easier and that's exactly what
wesley did he did play knight f1 and now
we see we're going to see what's up uh
levon sleeve he immediately played
bishop takes f1 queen takes f1 box
bishop takes
c1 i reckon
why do we have to take writing no i
don't i hate taking you you don't want
to but you can't think of anything h6
you know h6 is a useful move for sure
h6 is useful
uh queen e2 can be met by rookie 6 and
the rook is protected so that the pin uh
is not meaningful if we trade bishop e3
now rook e3
and uh
their the pawn on f3
as giving black
sufficient play i think
and the this is the position we have on
the board right now what's the position
we have on the book it's the one before
this so bishop f1 queen f1 and lavon
still seems to be thinking in this
position and unfortunately for him he is
um burning a lot of clock time but that
being said
if they're even like one more trade in
the position it would be a little bit
less risky for both players
so the bond sensing this is a critical
moment um what about eric's earlier move
queen h6 well i guess the problem now is
it actually doesn't threaten anything on
c1 because the queen defends that square
um and but it does have the idea let's
say queen h6 if you try to trade
everything off bishop d5 cd5 black just
wants to control the e file as a form of
counter plays so
if i trade like bishop d5 cd5 after
queen h6 then bishop e3 black would be
able to play queen e3 and we see
immediately by the way this move that i
didn't want to play
levon has simply captured on c1 and we
saw a quick recapture
uh bishop takes c1 rook takes c fourth
capture exactly because and now we now
we predict that levana is just going to
seize on the f3 pawn for counter play
here
something like rook e3 certainly looks
the most attractive doesn't it
but he has played king f8
a subtlety to be sure
just a quick note magnus is close to
winning against fabiano
wow
strategically speaking wow so
well
for
for all of uh the efforts that white has
made he still remains a pawn to the good
i would think that a
nice little move like queen f2 at this
moment
played in fact okay and was is that
three minutes to lavon's one nice so
levana could be very much in trouble
here
the problem with the marshals you need
to rely on memorization so much so
it's unclear if lebron has made a
slip up but it doesn't seem consistent
to play king i fade in g6 what do you
make of
that i feel like white has a good pawn
structure pawn up and i'm not seeing
enough compensation king g1
like even the end games if you give the
pawn back and play rookie one at some
point and give up f3
bishop should be better than the knight
g6 king g1 both on the board right and
and lavon going down levon going to 30
seconds um wow
it's very dangerous situation here for a
lot lavon but if we want to take a quick
look at our world champion um you
mentioned eric that he's very much on
top in this position and and boy that uh
knight on d4 it's a monster
monster i would uh i would swipe right
on pretty much every position
hey eric you swipe right on everything
you know well this is this is definitely
domination let's see if uh
in second place
this game is
likely to decide the second place
standings wesley so pawn up against
anish gary
can he
um maintain his extra pawn and just
drift closer and closer to technical
victory
yes indeed so magnus uh just a beautiful
play today
um but you know let's go and see about
that lavon game ever sell again because
that is so crucial as maurice mentioned
for
um second place and uh wesley can
actually be leading the grandchild store
if he secures a second place exactly
and the players are moving quickly i'm
waiting for my so i see levon played h5
maybe at some point when i played bishop
c2 and bishop e4
and
i'm just sorry i'll just switch back and
forth between the two boards to refresh
yeah bishop c2 and bishop e4 maybe he
should be e3 he's played c4 now
okay so he's played c4 which uh and now
he's maneuvered his bishop to f1
where it does some some job of
potentially defending the the pawn on f3
and the squares around the king
and after bishop f1 did we get a move i
think we said yeah we got rooster six
and followed by
wesley on move now wesley on move
so wesley would love to uh
somehow relieve the pressure here i
could say one thing the engines
certainly did not like c4 they preferred
keeping the pawn structure intact and uh
h4 g5 and things
i like
um
and now now the king is often exposed i
mean well hold on i would play hg queen
g4 rookie one if i were white
uh seeking to then h4
whoa we have moves that i don't have on
my board yeah that's right i think we
have hg5 queen g5
um
hd5 queen g5 rookie one as and h4 now
and then followed by h4 g4 so now 93
queen f4 uh at some point nine but 93
looks
mangas did win his game by the way you
guys fantastic wow 93 here ronin has
great counter chances here oh and boy
and blitz this is this is huge the bad
thing for lavon is he's he's the one in
massive time pressure so he's down to 10
seconds exactly 93 bishop bishop e3 on
the board 93 bishop where bishop h3
bishop h3 and now queen of four is the
move queen f4 just keeping
i keep just a few seconds left by
looks like lavon did he fly what
happened
i think he flagged it looked like he
might have flagged let's just find out
because there was a handshake in that
game um in an unclear position
except uh looks like you flagged and
deflected do you see that
yeah
his time went down to zero zero
wow so that is a huge result what other
games do we have eric in progress we
have nakamura against anand and kramnik
mvl oh nakamura anand just finished
kramnik mvl mvl is converting the
winning position as black looks like
nakamura lost by the way
no it was a draw guys oh it was a draw i
thought i saw the kings going the same
squares but it also looked like a bottom
could have lagged so that came just to
draw very
very impactful for the standings if
either player had won
um and we're watching the game between
vladimir kramnik and
mbl by the way nakamura got checkmated
by anand exactly brutal
and it does look like mvl is winning
as he has an extra exchange
as well as a past a pawn
and geary converting the
position here against topalov it looks
like
a nice nice little sequence there oh
i'm on the edge yeah yeah i got that i
got that um
i think if i was mvl i'd just be
bringing my king
over and just making sure i'm not
getting checkmated there is a rook b3 in
the position but i guess he's a little
bit worried about
fortresses
you see
and we have another score vessel and
toppolav
uh win yeah very decisive day
oh my goodness do we get a fortress
oops a correction
exactly
uh fortress uh light position
for
oh but this move rook d3 what's the
three
threatening
threatening uh and he's got and he's
managed to get e4 in and
that's uh and the h4 pawn is now lost so
that's there's no fortress that's the
end of the story now it is dead h pawn
is going to be crushing exactly
and now rook
just confidently by maxine he knows he's
got this game now and there goes the g
pawn and that's the game and they're all
falling down like dominoes whoa so
everybody round mvl uh comes up uh he
gains a half a point yeah that's
wrestling he's got 15 and a half now
though he's still well behind oh is he
well behind and we do have maurice
ashley with wesley so still in second
place here in the grand chess tour
well in a tie for first is wesley so of
course i'm just throwing out magnus's
score because that doesn't really matter
here but anyway wesley you must be
playing for something right now magnus
is clearly going to win this event he's
just playing uh incredible chess yeah
but there's a lot for you to play for a
lot at stake in this situation yeah
definitely of course i'll fight until
the very
rough game even if there's nothing
mistaken because that's why we played
chess
but yeah definitely i mean magnus won
the tormentor right now it's just a
fight for second place between uh
quite a lot of people now it matters
quite a bit as far as the grand chess
tour standings are concerned because you
did well in paris finishing fourth and
if you finish second here
without magnus's score
if considering naca and a couple of
other breaks you'll actually be the
leader in the grand chess tour does that
matter to you right now yeah of course
it matters for the qualification next
year everyone wants to play in the
manchester thanks to all the things very
nicely well done events but at the same
time it's too far ahead to think about
right now still
many months away for for qualification
next year but uh
you know just gotta focus on the next
three games and
and yeah this of course it's important
every game is important but uh still
looking for my first win today
absolutely well we wish you luck in
those games and yeah we'll see you later
ty right now wesley soul showing that he
is now comfortable in the grand chess
tour playing against all the big boys
well of course he's one of them too
thank you maurice and uh how did those
results affect our standings
uh probably a lot probably a lot but
most most important
point there is magnus running away and
everybody's happy because he's not going
to be qualified for the grand chess tour
overall
that's right magnus now has 22 points
wow so that is a that's a that's a
clinch for first right um wesley's got
18 and a half i think so yeah so the
three rounds to go we have our champion
and luven magnus carlson what do you
think eric you heard what i said i said
i'd swipe right on on everything magnus
has done he's just dominant it's
so enjoyable to watch he's so much
better than the rest of the field when
he's in in this sort of form
that's um that's that's really about it
lovely to watch the ambition i'm happy
i'm happy i got the predictions right
though we had that caller a few days ago
who
hasn't i haven't heard back from
the caller who was mocking eric for um
not picking on on um ana though he's
done okay still doing quite well
actually
now equal with leslie so in the race for
a second because he just won against
ikaro he's got 18 and a half too and
actually we we can look at it visually
see the standings are right here on on
with that victory moves into a tie with
leslie for second
magnus carlson clinched first
congratulations to our world champion
now the champion of leuven as well well
done
lavon oronion also very much on the hunt
for second place there's a big ten
points up for grabs for the number two
finisher and the stop at the grand theft
store so that's very important for the
final standings
go now to belgium for thoughts
from our
commentator
well it just looks like a heavyweight
against lightweights magnus carlsen
making it look so easy that everyone who
sits down in front of him almost knows
that they're headed to the guillotine
this guy is just dominating with ease
and again the fight for second place is
really important for the grand chess
tour but how can magnus be this much
better than the competition when you
talk to the top players in the world and
you ask them who's the best it's never a
question they never think oh maybe it's
me no it's magnus it's always magnus
carlsen and he's showing why
clean games better than the field wins
three rounds in advance
what else can you say
just absolutely stunning results but for
him it's normal magnus carlsen the best
player on the planet now the other games
were interesting as well very important
game
nakamura the winner in paris going down
again
i i've never seen icaru play blitz blitz
this badly if you had told me this i
predicted him winning the blitz portion
but if you told me no actually not only
is he not going to win he's going to be
the worst performer i would have said
come on let's be realistic that's not
possible and yet that's exactly what's
happening yeah he's had a bad tournament
i mean he just did horrible horrible
sermons he just didn't find his rhythm
at all he started with three losses in
love and he was unable to really come
back here vishyanan who's still fighting
for the very top spots he's uh i really
tied with wesley so yes at the very top
uh behind magnus he well he needs to
accumulate victories and this was a very
important one against ikaru uh it seems
like white's a little bit worse he's uh
equal amount of pawns but the other
collectors and the weak king you think
okay this is a long grind a lot of
things will happen and kicaro collapses
i mean there's another way of putting it
after bishop e3 which is fine
kf8 he carves at a4 maybe i'll break on
a5 bishop b4
a5 and then
vishi said well i really don't care
about what you're doing on the queen
side i'm just going to check with you so
he brings in the rook and a horrible
blunder because he can still save the
game kind of with bishop g5 it would be
worse but the past a pawn means that
black will have a tempo attack instead
this horrible move h4 which just lets
himself get mated after rook h3 really
encompasses how hikaru has been playing
in this tournament i mean hanging maiden
three hikaru nakamura in blitz that just
shows that his mind is shot he's not
interested in the tournament at all the
worst part for him is that he can't get
any grandchild points or any significant
points from this event but great for him
he gets to throw out his worst result
automatically throwing out the worst
results here means that he's going to
have to do well in the sink field cup
and in london
and i think that means that wesley's
soul in my opinion is in the driver's
seat with only maxim vashila grav sort
of chasing him because he has two
results now and he doesn't have to throw
out either one of them
he can look to see how he does in the
next two events and then just pick them
it's hard to say for me everybody in the
field will be throwing up throwing out
either paris or leuven even wesley
except for wesley and that's the thing
except for wesley i think everybody's
going to be throwing out one of the two
results if they're going to try to win
the grand chess tour so it's very hard
to keep favorites of course wesley
having two strong results he still has
to come into the same
of a strong mentality he didn't perform
well last year it's complicated
classical so it's still hard to predict
who's going to do well it's very
important how they finish in leuven
remember that vishyanan doesn't have the
ability to just uh mess up another
tournament he already threw out paris
because he didn't play so for me the
players that i think might still have
good chances i'm looking at ironian i
think that he had a good chance
you got a ronin i got i got wesley i got
wesley and who did who did he pick he
picked the bond alejandro picked the
bond i picked lavon okay i'll pick
nakamura
i'm hiking hikaru
i'm also taking uh hikaru
all right so we got uh what do you say
fabiano carolina
he's not going to say
bobby well there you go so we got a guy
we got two believers in nakamura though
that he's gonna come back i honestly i'm
just a math girl i'm looking at the i'm
looking at the math and i'm saying he
carl is dropping this result right
anyway so he's already got this massive
13 points and that's huge because there
might be ties in the other events much
more likely for there to be a tie in an
event with uh only nine rounds than in
these um blitz games where you have so
much differentiation because there's so
many games in fact i was thinking this
year in the grand chess world
grand chester by the way um there is now
this year unlike last year um the tour
points will be split if there are ties
okay so if you're tied for instance for
third through fourth that's um eight
points for third and a four seven so
instead of getting the full eight if you
finish the head
exactly and last year didn't work that
way
and i think because it works that way
this year um that's good because there
will be less luck of the draw
exactly and um also another thing you
want to notice about the test drawer
points is that second place is very
important because it's 13 or 12 for
first
second is 10 and then it starts just
going one by one right and then it's
second so it's so it's 13 10 8 and then
it's just one by one for the rest of the
clients exactly
and let's take a look at the stops on
the tour
well we've got the sink field cup coming
up not that far away this is a little
earlier than most years so those of you
who are thinking about it make your
plans to come to st louis in august it's
always such a great event there are side
events there's a chess museum there's a
live commentary great food you're going
to want to come out to st louis same
thing london in december a fantastic
stop to visit in person of course we're
going to be doing commentary for these
events if you're not able to make it
live but i highly suggest you
come out and check out the action in
person at least for a couple days
absolutely no they and the cinco cup
here in the us it's just such a great
it's such a great event and eric you've
got the energy baby what's happening i'm
excited classical chess and uh looking
forward to that especially because the
wild card for the singfelt cup is
dingley wren so i'm i'm just excited
strong field classical chess it's a good
mix
chinese they caught me out that was that
was unintentional yeah yeah yeah the
more dante i know er we uh woke up here
at uh 3 a.m for the early start and
america had some techno music to get us
all rammed up
just
get get ready
that sounds like a good idea maybe we
need to combine that with the push-ups
techno and push-ups and jazz
and we are going to take a short break
as we do some push-ups and listen to
some more music and we'll be right back
with the um third to last round we've
got three more rounds left here in
move-in
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the grand
chess tour
and we've got uh this
match for second place in this stop but
really uh first place in regards to the
grand chess tour well of course
clinched last round
and just a beautiful game so where would
you like to go do you want to see
lebron's game against hikaru yes that's
a good that's a game very much worth
watching i was also just keeping an eye
on the game poops between vessel and
topalov and so yes that's one of our
italian games which we've been seeing so
much of um here we though let's stick
with this one though because this is an
opening we haven't seen as much in
this tour that's absolutely it's uh
nimzo indian with knight f3 and bishop
g5
players have been playing very quickly
lavone aronian
and hikaru nakamura as we know had that
very nice match
uh two years ago here in st louis it was
with the chess 960
exactly blitz and rapid right he won
that match
but this is blitz this is five plus two
and uh we have and of course we're
having a terrible tournament and so
important for him as i mentioned er
mentioned earlier the scores are so
scrunched up at the bottom that if he
actually wins this game he could go up
as many as like three points
in terms of his manchester points that
being said probably this result is
getting thrown out anyway yes most
likely i mean unless he performs quite
badly in uh st louis or london so
it's it's actually more for pride i'd
say is at stake for him and also
some security in case he
for instance wins one of those stops and
does terribly in the other one which is
certainly something that he always have
to do um he's still it might be the
difference of a point that'll that'll
win in the tour well i tell you i mean
for me jennifer i'm just having a
difficulty digesting the fact that icaru
could have been so dominant one week ago
and then suddenly uh struggling for his
life
in this
event in belgium uh you said he just
looks tired
and i think that's about as good an
explanation as
as i can offer as well he's also missing
some of his food he beat fresney really
badly in paris and
now we've sought them for anand who is
making a huge impact on the field that's
a big factor uh i mean those are a few
points and they all everyone has clients
in the field and everyone has tough
opponents and he it was a bad swap in
that case
that's a good point although i thought
that nakamura's actually done very well
against anand in the past yes
just in the very previous game the
checkmate that vishy was about to
deliver to
hikaru that looked like a very dominant
game by the former world champion
five-time world champion
um from india now what do you make of
this position i mean it looks like it
looks like somehow as nakamura said in
that a very well done in um interview
with uh spectrum studios where they
showed how the players feel about blitz
and stopping the bleeding and nothing
talked about how important that was
right i feel like he's playing less
ambitiously and it must be because of
that
it seems like in a lot of the games that
he's played in this tournament in
particular he's he's gone for um less
sharp lines like against wesley
you saw him play that kind of early
queen trade and actually get the worst
of it yes that game with wesley and also
his game with magnus where it was very
balanced and he just frankly he got
simply outplayed i mean from personal
experience playing hikaru i think the
players are getting used to his good
active counter play they're just
improving by playing him specifically
they know nakamura is very uh good at
defending bad positions they know he's
very tactical and the players are are
watching out for that and they're
avoiding steering away from a lot of his
strengths we haven't seen a lot of
trademark nakamura come from behind wins
and i think a lot of that is due to the
opponents adjusting um that's been my
experience when i play him once you play
a couple hours at least you start to
you know pick up on on a few of his uh
strengths and and try to avoid
certain sorts of positions that he
really excels in that he can just
play ten moves in a row we're not seeing
those structures that in paris where he
would have a fortress or a setup where
he could make really easy moves he's not
getting those easy to play positions and
blockades yeah i think that's a very
good point eric just the adjustments
that the pilots are making
not giving him uh positions that he
excels in sorry jennifer
keep in mind there's that two second
increment nakamura seems like the
fastest player in the field but i'm not
sure how much that matters it doesn't
matter but it definitely matters last in
a situation where there are the two
second increments now this game um
i was thinking maybe we could move to
vessel and topalov's game against wesley
which looks quite rich well it's funny
that despite having a lofty lead magnus
is playing the sharpest game out of all
the players that's just a side note
sorry to interrupt you i'm just saying
that vessel and topolof might have
fallen for a very
sweet little tactic he just played the
move bishop h4
trying to pin this knight to the queen
wesley said pin what
what pin
knight takes e4 with the knight takes f2
uh threat in case you take the queen and
there's a four that would leave us up
two pawns in the end of the day i think
you you made you made a mess slip you
meant to play with your takes d8
yes
but
well in fact it was knight takes g4 it
didn't that was played i see yeah yeah
but you were the very reason you wanted
to show us was that efficient v8
takes f2 um and black wins the house yes
did wesley play knight f2 because knight
c3 was computer choice it's saying
knight f2 is very balanced after just
trading everything off
no no no
it's knight takes e4 knight takes g4 yes
and
mistake uh i think knight takes c3 was
much stronger and we had a massive trade
on f2 and
played rookie three so now
we're up upon but our king is in in
pretty ugly situation
yeah yeah so like that should give up
king g1 was much better than rookie 3
here is now you can play queen f6 and
after ab5 you can throw in rook f8
threatening checkmate whereas if you
play king g1 queen f6 not possible
because you can just take back on b5 and
rook f8 wouldn't be checkmated so you're
just saying rookie three weakened the
first rank oh oops
we're going to get your board back
but now eric in this particular position
do you think that vaseline has full
compensation for the pawn no not at all
i prefer uh black's uh open f file
that's a great asset in this position
he's up upon no i i think wesley has a
great chance here probably gonna play
queen g5 rook a8 to f8 just take control
over the gnf files the queen of the rook
put pressure on h5 but the queen and the
live chat so just queen g5 double rooks
on the f file
easy to play
h5 you can't get this rook into the game
so i think wesley is in full control in
this position
so i'm really expecting queen g5 here
then doubling the rooks so even if you
take here yes you can take back well
actually that's starting checkmate so i
have to move sorry has to play like
something like rook g3 maybe then queen
queen five or try to trade queens the
end games are favorable for uh
wesley and the metal game is favorable
with with this file well this is really
huge for wesley so because if he wins
this game with the black pieces he'll be
on 19 and a half
and the only one who will be able to
catch him pretty easily it would be
vicious
yes
and he's played queen f7 uh fortifying
the h5 pawn so now wesleyan can play
rook f3 or now he can play queen c1
check he did play queen c1 yeah yeah and
um after king g6 that's the position we
have in the board now
so once again if you take on b5 i'm
going to block is going to play uh rook
f8
and a quick rook g3 check and king h7
i know it looks like a h3 making lift
leslie trying not to get too far behind
on the clock he's already done a full
moon look i think rook g8 should be
played
he once played
yes um
once he's really got to battle against
the clock here he's down a whole minute
almost
moving his queen closer to her you can
never be too sure
never too early
well king h2 just
and queen f4
and that pretty much forces a clean
trade because of h4 uh the threat but
that just this only helps black correct
this pawn structure after queen f4 ef4
that's right we don't have to worry
about our our naked king anymore that's
for sure
so you predict that after queen f4
you're going to see a pawn capture eric
yes
and undouble those bonds
absolutely
absolutely and uh be able to get the
move in f3 as well
right
and uh how do you assess uh levon's
chances there now it's even in pawns at
the moment um lavon is thrown in the
move g5 and wesley of course defending
with uh oh sorry it's a pot sorry
vaseline this one played uh
can't work g5 and h4 interpolated those
moves
i think this is too easy a play for uh
wesley as he's just preparing to play
the move rook on rookie one e5 should
probably be played right away
yeah and was played rook f8 to f4 is
coming with threats to the h4 pawn which
is supporting the rook on g4 its pawns
are just so weak that this end game
should be lost d3 c3 all just simple
targets
and easier to access than the c7 pawn
for
black big win there by so if he manages
to finish the job yeah it's a question
of time i have been told by the way
that the magnus train has had a hiccup
and that he has some
well he sacrificed the piece he played a
very sharp opening and he only has nine
seconds left so if you want to move over
there now's the time
but it really was magnus taking the risk
himself
yeah well now he um just would like to i
guess make history and uh he's sounding
fun it looks like he's having fun yeah
why not he's clinched tournament victory
he's cleans first place money
um why not have some fun and see how
badly he can uh crush people
lots of trades as the players were
playing very quickly
onish a little bit uncertain but
did play the move knight c6
that's right and this is definitely not
easy
and uh
nakamura
loss
is that is that confirmed because of
position that it might be i'm not sure
no no it doesn't
actually the game was a draw yes 18 and
a half points now for levon but if um
if wesley indeed wins he's gonna be a
full point ahead of levon with two
rounds to go
uh
has lost uh very badly to so it's game
over he was down three pounds and he
resigned and it's all about vichy then
let's see this let's see if this uh
carlson game racked up he only got two
seconds left on the clock oh my gosh he
just barely made it
rook
bishop g6 h2
bishop f5 to g6 sorry
you're okay to check
and we see oh this is totally over and
magnus carlson finally getting stopped
but it's too late it is too late
mathematically they can't get two points
in the game so they cannot catch magnus
carlsen of course
he's very competitive how you don't get
the world champion without being hyper
competitive he doesn't like losing the
game exactly but he was really pressing
it there uh i didn't unfortunately i had
an issue with my board how did vichy
anand do in that round they're still
playing they're still playing right now
uh yes sir i got the board over here
it's an end game kramnik playing black
now looks like it just ended in a draw
after queen d3 check here both kings uh
you know uh open so that game was a draw
so wesley still moves into clear second
then with that win with a half a point
lead over vichy with two rounds to go
that's right two rounds to go and wesley
soh in second
and magnus carlsen of course still
clinching the tournament but showing
that he is human today thank goodness
he was otherwise having a 3500 result it
was just incredible what he was doing in
this i mean he played a grand prix
attack where he sacrificed upon the
opening it's
not a no
probably the riskiest opening anybody
has played the whole event i mean yes
he's been playing extremely uh risky
openings all throughout the tournament
knight or stonewall just unbelievable
loco indians nimzo indians he's really
mixed it up
yeah i think that
um
wesley's had a really interesting
tournament where sometimes we're so
impressed by this play and then
sometimes he just doesn't seem to bring
it but overall the thing that you notice
about him is that
when i think there's been a couple of
positions where he was a little better
and it started to slip away and he found
those right moments to at least get the
draw well he said it best in the rapid
chess portion that what his goal was to
simply score every game either half a
point or a point just to avoid losses
and it worked really well through two
days of action and then finally he got
knit in the blitz in day three
but he still is playing very well and
he's got that second point second place
pardon me
right now
by half a point and you see a lot of
emotional stability from wesley too like
other players have had so many blunders
and ups and downs like kramnik and
fabiano and of course yukaru right
whereas wesley is steady yeah
so and steady if you like well magnus
has been the most consistent but
wesley's second and that's why he's in
second that he's he's actually played a
very good game a very good tournament
sorry you don't like so and steady so
instead
well it's a lot of action in the town
square right now we're hearing bell
tolling we're hearing somebody hopping
on something
if i was in brooklyn i think that
banging noise was something else but
definitely hustle and bustle but here in
the tournament hall we have magnus
showing his stuff it's so dominant when
a player wins a tournament like this he
just you don't know what to say because
he's just so far ahead of the pack and
now he's just playing around let me sack
upon here let me sack upon there peace
here peace there whatever he's going to
completely win this event
if he was to play somehow sneak into
saint louis or or london i don't think
that's allowed by the rules but he'd win
the grand chess tour easily well uh i
don't think we're going to see any more
of this type of games from magnus
carlsen even though he has secured first
place here in leuven he still wants to
end the tournament as a top-rated blitz
player in the world and he is one loss
away from uh dropping to second just
behind dingley ren who will be joining
the grand chess tour i believe as a wild
card in the singfield cup but yeah i
think magnus wants to finish with a high
point he won't be doing any kind of
foolishness like he did against anish
anymore i think but
he's just dominant and wesley so good
for him that he actually won with black
against topalov who
in paris did very well in the last day
today not so much i think wesley needed
this point it's distances have half a
point over anon a full point over
ironian and for the grand chess tour
standings that's a big deal absolutely
and with two rounds to go it's still
anybody's race for second that is
but they're going to play for it there's
money on the line as well it's not like
they can just say whatever there is real
money to be made different between
second and third and fourth places so
they'll be playing for all the marbles
with the next two rounds yet to come
thank you
thank you gentlemen and here's actually
the prize money 37 500 that's already
been wrapped up by magnus carlson it's
such a big difference between second and
third in fact uh right that's insane
third fourth and fifth are all exactly
the same and second is a big bonus right
thirty thousand dollars versus fifteen
so
definitely a nice big fight for that
second prize but boy that's a big drop
off
indeed
interesting interesting
prize breakdown indeed not not uh not
very typical but i think that at this
level with all the players being very
successful financially a lot of it has
to do with grand chest for standings
and the importance of
and the importance of getting um
the honor of winning a stop and of
course ultimately hoping to win the
entire tour right well there you see the
blitz scores magnus looking supreme with
ten but wesley so scoring eight and a
half and nine
for uh bishop actually she's got the
second best of good score indeed exactly
and a couple of people with eight and a
half right really bunched up except for
vessel and magnus though right i mean
maxine's looking okay with eight
lighterman cramming with eight probably
not come on again mostly plus one
even or minus one right um
it shows how tight this field is in the
grand chest store and how really anybody
can beat anybody exactly that's what we
love about it with two rounds to go 19
and a half 19 19
and a half so you think um leslie is
going to hold his second place all right
the way he's playing yes he's winning
the games he has to win despite taking
losses he he's won a lot more games than
he did in paris and maybe in the first
two days of the rapper here so his clear
instincts there he's finding the tactics
and the critical moments and he seems to
be very comfortable with beating the
players who are not so comfortable in
these faster time controls only thing
i'm worried about is if magnus keeps us
up i might lose my prediction over who
wins the wrap that i mean he just threw
the kitchen sink at geary which is one
of the few ways uh to give himself good
losing chances when he's playing white
against saanich and we do have a big
matchup next round wesley silver's
magnus carlson so we are going to be
right back with that critical game as we
see if wesley can hold his second place
standing
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the grand chester in moving where we
do have a winner world champion magnus
carlson playing some sizzling chads i
mean which memory of magnus sticks out
to you the most which game
wow uh well the game that he just
steamrolled mvl that is an unbelievable
game he just uh with the black
but foreign drama is for the second
place and a high drama we have as we go
into the penultimate game where magnus
carlsen just played a coffee house-like
game against onish gary and it didn't
work badly in fact wesley so playing for
the second place has the white pieces
against magnus eric eric your
your thoughts and predictions
wesley is being pretty clutch
but when facing magnus magnus doesn't
need to win here i think this game is
going to fizzle out to a draw
all right
you know unfortunately i actually
agree with your prediction just because
wesley so does seem that he occasionally
takes that route and that would be a
decent result against magnet of course
but i on the other hand i think magnus
is really good at tempting people like
in that nbl game i mean of course well
it's good there there's no question
about that the czech binoni can't be one
of the best openings in chats not
possible no no no no everybody fires if
it works but on the other hand i mean
with the pressure off on magnus
pressure on wesley magnus has been
very coy a droid at
mixing his defenses up
and magnus
wants to go out on a high note so i
think a lot of pressure on wesley in
this game and i see magnus is
putting the pressure on we'll see how it
goes magnus were to play at this level
like he's played today he'll be the
first player to have a 3000 rating in
chess blitz it's a lot more possible i
mean he's 2 900 blitz 3000 is definitely
mathematically possible so
i mean that would be a motivation that
he might have to find for himself like
these games will count towards that
great point eric and remember that just
yesterday um actually carlson had
slipped in the blitz rankings and ding
lorraine was number one
carlson now back number one no surprise
there and certainly wants to stay there
but one thing's for sure in this game
whoever wins will have a really nice
smile
no question about it and we're seeing a
dutch
and knight c3 on move to
by
wesley
uh he's just avoiding uh some of the
more common stonewall types as well as
leningrad dutches and i'm just getting
uh updated there we have they hear what
do you do you wait for black to play c5
you usually play bishop d3 you take on
c5 and you try to play c4 yourself and
play
a no risk
sort of position you mean
like this yes yeah y plays bishop d3
castles because white's not playing c4
not taking the center not challenging it
so instead white tries to chip away at
it at it i think bishop d3 c5 you take
something like that
yeah
well uh for me i really
hate the positioning of this knight on
c3 i might
flip it quickly to f4 and back to d3
knight on c3 just
perturbs me let's say does it appeal to
my sense of aesthetics and i'd be trying
to cure it but you were right he went
for the bishop d3 right away and uh
magnus did not
go for the immediate c5 he simply went
bishop e7
and castle so here we have
how it all unfolded and i think i'm up
to date
i'm looking at the webcam have i
am i up to date uh jennifer um it seems
that way yeah
good
so again um my sense of aesthetics is
that i i really want to move this knight
the other idea if i had an idea for
white in the position it would be to
play h3g4
and finally i could go for a kind of a
pillow door
this this isn't the most challenging
line against the
the dutch and black will have a
reasonable position uh definitely but
guess what wednesday's already up about
a minute on the clock that is definitely
something to write home about in blitz
absolutely maurice said that it's worth
a piece of course he meant later in the
game this is earlier in the game it's
not worth the beast yeah maybe half a
pawn that two second increment can be
big i think if i was magnus in this
position i'd be very tempted by the move
b7 b6 in order to support the advanced
c5
uh the other uh obvious way is to play
knight b8 d7 and c5 and we have moves
yes 94 in a trade on e7 oh it was knight
e4 okay that kind of no i'll trade off
the iceberg bishops knight e2
and after c5 play c4 so i would if 94 i
would take on e7 i think 94 has been
played
taken and that's exactly what happened
and then he played 92 right away to
prepare c4 right so well
i'm not sure i agree with what black did
there but i think that really helped
white yes essentially uh that
trade
pardon me that trade of dark square
bishops
by the way to prevent c4
uh
a magnificent 1966.
all right
rook c1 then and uh well you can't
really stop b3 c4 trying to figure out
what the counter play is
uh besides c5 because uh
well generally i mean this should just
be a bit better for white with a
better bishop and after one magnus just
played knight d7
so c4 could even be possible here and
he's played c4
uh magnus playing c6
and so
magnus not deciding to take twice on c4
because the knights will also end up
becoming very strong in this position
you haven't again you have that iso on
c8
yes i think i would just plant the
knight on e5 at this moment encourage
the trade of knights on e5 and try to
play
uh
good night bad bishop versus bad bishop
sorry what did he play queen d3 and one
of the others
exactly queen a3 playing on the dark
squares yep and hey he's done it queen
b3
and uh magnus played something and then
there was this king aj king aj was
played king h8 queen e3 and then a5
a5 and again
b5 at some moment
i think magnus has simply misplayed this
and i think that after knight e5 i i
really have a big preference for him if
i played and magnified
felt compelled to play king back to g8
what are you serious looks it looks like
that's what happened i mean obviously
there's like some misplacement of the
king now because if your rook were to
move we could have had this little
tactic of queen d6 and knight seven jack
but um
still
a big advantage suddenly for wesley so i
didn't expect this play by uh
magnus and he's backed the night up with
f4 f2f4 and then then we did see rookie
eight again um he wanted to play rookie
eight disallowing queen d6 queen v6 and
knight s7 which would be totally winning
when the king was on h8 right but
obviously not the ideal moves to play
king having king james
no especially in being down an entire
minute on the clock far from ideal
indeed but magnus has escaped worse well
this is about as bad
a
stone wall as black could possibly
achieve his weight night on uh knight f6
uh sorry it was magnificent oh it was um
after rookie eight oh i think he's
played a work c2 or something but maybe
you update the board cause i'm not
totally sure
and um eric's got a extreme situation
from another game well yasser was
talking about his sense of aesthetics
i'm not sure
what he means about that but i'm
wondering what do you oh let me i want
to show you a pawn structure that came
in this game
and
what you think about it this was the
game gary against mvl sharp grunfeld
look at these triple pawns on the e file
it's one of those end games i mean you
can even win a pawn is white but it's so
fractured that uh let's say
you just can't win what do you think
about this
well
it certainly is a violation of the of
yours there's no rules of aesthetics no
question about it i'm not a big fan of
the irish pun structure our response
what's the that's the triplets you keep
using these words that he doesn't
understand yeah
i didn't know there was an irish bond
structure
well i don't think the irish are proud
but
hey i'm heart island there you go there
you go
uh but so nbl slightly preferable here
because of this brutal brutal structure
right
and let's go back and see how wesley is
if he is nursing that advantage um we
see that uh
carlson has tried to trade knights on g4
which he has achieved he's managed to do
that um so that changes the character of
the position a little bit
um because now it's very hard for us to
maneuver on the knight to the juiciest
square of all e5
we would have to move our bishop and our
rook and it would take a lot of twisting
and turning because we can't use the f3
square of course well uh the twisting
and turning uh however long it takes
should begin and i think it should get
underway in earnest how many moves does
it take do you want knight c1 bishop e2
well i would go knight g3 king back to
g1 knight h1 knight f2 it looks like
wesley's choosing a different route he
played rook e1 rook e1 so he's going
with your choice of knight c1 and then
maybe bishop e2 hitting the pawn for a
moment okay we do have to watch out for
the e4 square ourselves
queen h4
not a big fan of being induced to
playing the move g3
so
i thought a very big advantage for
wesley
maybe he's been tempered a bit in the
last several moves so you don't like
this uh this execution rather and we do
it seems like we're having a flurry of
moves on the board if you want to get
caught up yeah i have a auto catch up
but i also have an autocad
sometimes they play too fast
okay and this is the position we've got
18 seconds left to three minutes oh my
god i think this is what maurice was was
talking about when he said it was up but
yeah aronian has a great great position
here so we might want to catch the
finish of this
yeah i mean there aren't too many moves
for arnold here
big game for the standing huge game c4
best move aronian will leapfrog over
anand if he wins this game he'll have 19
and a half and anon will stay at 19.
we just saw trade on g6 and
after the smooth c5 c4
knight takes g6 knight takes g6
very very quickly played well he's
trying to play quickly because that's
his only edge the clock right
levin is the one who's uh doing it it's
very easy to get used to getting in time
trouble and aronian found this similar
situation against wesley so he might be
addicted to
that low time that adrenaline
there are worse addictions
but there are meetings for those we have
to ask
about the time travel addiction
and after we take c4 and just like
lavon's lavon's position is is uh is
beautiful right he's just up in exchange
i i like it i feel like black has a lot
of compensation on the dark side queen
g3 rook takes c4 queen g3 i don't think
lavon has actually played this exchange
up
that impressively
queen g3 and he's played queen h5
um now something came to d2 it actually
wasn't the rock it was the bishop
keep the queens on the board because
that'll be unpleasant to deal with right
so what happened after bishop d2 um
queen c4 and uh queen e5 i believe and
then f4 by i think there was a position
yeah
uh king h1 queen
and e5 preparing king g7 rook h8
exactly so was even a queen
h8 looks like there's an f4 queen b2
f3 f4 queen b2
being uh
still the massive time pressure here for
lavon was just eight seconds left so he
has to decide on his moves before anon
makes them bishop d4 f5
immediate king g7 by uh
fishy is that right
queen
g3
i'm trying
oh wesley carlson i've been told has
been made as have made a draw
and
vishy climbing back into this game yes
and i think we'll just go to the big
they are playing overheads quickly or
the or the sideways shot indeed
here we see that um aronian has gained
some time back and
he's got an extra pawn but there's a
very nicely placed knight on e5
to stop
even if you lose the e4 pawn you go for
the a5 pawn outside passer with the
bishop very effective he's going to
prepare that at some point protecting
all of the clones and notice he's gained
something there we go there we go just
as you predicted
king b6 then yes and this is
this is big big advantage outside past
pawn with the bishop one of the best
combos
you can have
absolutely
is he gonna take no
we didn't have to do it but he's gonna
play rook a2
very soon yes rook a2
uh oh this is a very good this is very
good this is very yes there you have it
this this uh this should be we should be
ready yes behind the passport
another good combo pizza and beer
playing with 20 seconds against three
minutes
wow holding a school in a very sharp
position yeah and going from like five
seconds to 23 seconds that means you
needed to play every every move in one
second guys
is it gonna be two queens on the board
and there we go it is you should have
waited to see if lavon made a queen
yes
and
this tournament has really been one of
rook endings and checkmating attacks i
see uh in the game of honesty and the
others who are also chess found
absolutely perfect
and it looks like vladimir kramnik has
resigned
and again we've got this uh marvelous
rook ending
one interesting struggle is carl fabiano
keeps beating kramnik e4 e5 testing the
berlin and succeeding it's been one of
his bright spots and this is a
completely theoretical end game here
yeah a classic draw as the defending
king is too close
uh to the promotion square
that's right so even though you play
rook v8 it doesn't win because you can't
actually extricate your king and they've
agreed to live
but another one that you can study
because if the king is not placed as
close it actually ends up being a
victory for wyatt so it's a good one to
look at
you know we've seen a lot of a pawn in
games yeah a lot of rookies and games
with an apon right and usually there's
been some kingside pawns as well
uh to give the uh superior side a chance
and there's some great sections on that
in the dovetail game and what's your
favorite um end game book by the way for
those types of rook engines uh
definitely the smithslav
is that stolen is that still an only
descriptive though they got an algebraic
version
we'll find out
i don't know
and eric what's your favorite at game
bug
good question no different keys is what
i've been uh using i don't actually know
too well about the book that yasser was
referring to
i'll admit i don't know
you know but
actually this year i got karsten
mueller's new rook and game book and
i've been enjoying that one as well so
is that the really big one like uh
no no no no it's a new one from this
year okay but otherwise impressions west
is so
holding on to that uh second place
because anna took a hit there so his
strategy has paid off as we said we
predicted it might be a draw he might be
happy with the drawings magnus but
that's banking on ana not surging and so
that looks like it's going to pay off
for him
and i'm just going uh through that game
between
uh
wesley and magnus because we were
watching it
for a while and it looked like just at
the end there was this repetition we see
these types of repetition very often
the very active black rook white doesn't
want to do with it and so a draw was
agreed
how that happened and after this
penultimate
how does that affect our standings
because fishy losing right well it is
pretty similar it's just a different
contender for a second right before we
had um
lavon
before we had this sheet now we have
exactly before we had vishy and nipping
at wesley's heels now it's um lavon
instead
and we've got grandmaster maurice ashley
with a very special guest
former world champion and human rights
activist gary kasparov wow okay shout
out to gary
and you can add to those accolades a
visionary
of all kinds of proportions
gary first of all always great to be in
your presence thanks for joining us
you see the grand chess tour and you see
magnus carlsen the way he has played
he's just making it clear that he's head
and shoulders above the rest you used to
do this once back in the day once or
twice back in the day what's it like
when you're done with the tournament
you've dominated it and you have really
almost nothing to play for how do you
get the motivation of the juices to
finish off strong
um now i have to say that when magnus
plays chess
it looks easy
because you know he makes the moves and
the opponents make their moves but at
the end of the day you know he's in most
of the cases he prevails um
yeah i think that's very important at
magnus and that's i could you know see
resemblance with fischer or as myself
you know he's he's fighting with his own
excellence so it's it's always to win
more it's always actually you know to
find mistakes he made you know you see
me you know coming back
out of the stage and it's at least if he
hasn't won a winning game i mean just
he's you know really he's suffering so
it's this is a very important quality
which guarantees that he's not going to
stop
i know now and it's and uh it's you know
it will there's always room for him to
make progress and again it's it's great
for the game of chess absolutely great i
love the way you put that he suffers
when he doesn't win the game even though
he's got the tournament
is important so and that's the that's
the you know best sign that he's his
progress he you know he is still he's
still he's still making his progress you
know he hasn't completed his you know
his chest maturity because he he has
this passion and he has his
hunger just to to get even better with
every game with every move absolutely
and he has made a really strong showing
of support by deciding to play in the
grand chester even though he can't
finish by playing in the sink field cup
and london chess classic shows that he
believes that this is a great trend for
chess which is a great speech
which is of course a big loss because
you know it's the uh uh especially after
this phenomenal performance in leuven uh
magnus is a clear favorite and it's just
even playing one was three out of four
you know he could have still expected
you know just you know providing you
know we could we we had three out of
four best results so but uh
it's it's it's another problem that we
have a calendar that is filled with real
events and imaginary events and
and while you know branches to us build
you know strong presence you know on the
other side on the feeder side we still
have you know a lot of talks and
sometimes you know events you know being
announced but uh they are either not
materialized or they're materializing
you know the last minute which is
causing tremendous damage since you know
grandchildren's tour is about to build
sponsorship it's about to bring it yes
let's focus on that the sponsors that
you're bringing in to the grand chess
tour we saw a great sponsor in vivendi
in paris now we have another big company
here in leuven sponsoring
how's the trend going it looks like the
trend is positive look it's the the
discussion now is whether we should look
for the expansion in 2017 because at
least you know
as if today the 2017 is not that busy
with so-called official phoenix calendar
there's no world championship match uh
there's no olympics there's a of course
the world cup uh uh
as announced
in september which could you know um
ultra dates for sinful cup again uh uh
in 2017. but in in in theory we can look
for five or six events and there are no
there are requests there are serious
opportunities you know to be to uh to be
explored uh but what is important that
we have four events i mean four solid
events you know two classic uh a simple
cap and london classic and uh two rap
blitz uh paris and and uh leuven that
already you know agreed to to carry on
for the next year so uh you know
whatever happens though before i i hope
that we'll move to five for six you know
just uh to bring more players because if
you expand number of tournaments you
have a chance actually to invite you
know not just ten players uh nine
players in this but but to invite uh 14
or 15 players well that said uh
bringing in more players
is there an off chance a wild card spot
might be given to one gary kasparov to
come in and play a little rapid blitz no
i look it's still it's still too much
for me so i i'm enjoying watching it so
i recently joined gary in the ultimate
blitz you look pretty good i'm sorry i
saw some good games i'm very blundering
like this even though you're hungry
yeah so i have no plans you know they'll
come back you know it's the it's that
i'm i'm enjoying watching it so that's
why i mean it takes something you know
quite dramatically just to change my
position here to one at stage indeed
that well said
who do you think is going to win it now
that we take magnus out of it what's
your prediction for who's going to win
it given the circumstances
you know the problem is just you know no
matter who wins it you know in the mind
of the public you know this is the first
portals are taken by magnus i mean the
way he played here we always you know
just it's okay
obviously obviously nakamura has an
excellent chance because you know you
want paris uh and you know um
and since mangoes was second in paris i
mean nobody you know gets the the prize
for the second here magnus won the
tournament so nakamura is his best
position he he played classic whites you
know solidly last year you know um and
uh i think
as if now when we look at the the way
that the these players you know uh
uh uh fought um i would say that his
chances mathematically speaking they are
probably preferable uh though again it's
it's it's full of surprises um and uh i
think that you know just caruana could
play phenomenal uh
uh
classic chess uh and uh you know look um
any any of these players almost anybody
could surprise us and i i expect more
from gary eventually from mvl so we'll
see what happens
we will see what happens but we always
know it's a pleasure to have you with us
and thanks very much for the work that
you continue to do to expand the great
sport not only where you're such a great
player but a great ambassador of the
game thank you thank you morris gary
casparov
one of the greatest of all times my
opinion the greatest of all times in
terms of tournament performance and
excellence absolutely a legend and we're
always thrilled to have him be with us
and happy that he's a visionary for the
grand chess tour
thank you maurice and thank you gary uh
just a quick clarification that what
gary was talking about is that we had to
move the dates for the sinkhole cup due
to fide moving the olympiad in where
everybody was very upset about that
then we still don't know about the world
championship match in november
because
while it's been announced new york we
don't know venues we don't know a lot of
important details here here are the
uh next grand chester stops
right two wonderful cities and come on
down and watch us
watch the action on hold in person for a
few days at least it's definitely worth
the trip
and let's take a look at where we stand
in this tournament magnus carlson on top
by two and a half points is one round
ago
reminiscent of nakamura in paris
meanwhile wesley so he's got a 20 points
so the thinnest of margins over lavon
oroneon and uh that's what we're going
to be keeping our eyes peeled on for the
final round is it going to be lavon or
wesley who captures those uh 12 those 10
grand tester points and picks up the
most of players who are in the tour
absolutely we'll be right back to find
out
[Music]
so
hello everybody and welcome back to
lumen belgium and the grand chess tour
as we are getting ready underway
uh for the
final round of blitz here in the fourth
day of competition it's been a marvelous
competition and it's been marvelous
magnus carlson world champion putting
his print firmly on this event as he
gets set up for his final game
against hikaru nakamura these two
players were the dominant players in
paris ikaru definitely having a bad
event here jen that's right but this is
a very important rivalry in the world of
chess of course nakamura has done
terribly against magnus carlsen in
classical chess but he did knock him
down in this tournament in the rapid
portion um of course it was more magnus
carlson knocking himself down
but a win is a win right eric what do
you think about this
famous matchup
oh i i love it uh in classical it's just
not a rivalry necessarily but uh these
two players are such
so skilled uh intuitively they're really
fast really
they're i love watching them they're
young guys who enjoy playing but i'm
also going to be keeping my eye out for
the other two games with wesley and
lavon because who knows uh how ambitious
magnus is he's already
you know won the event
hey didn't you listen to gary he's been
doing worse with white than he has with
black the last two days so in case this
peter's out we have a couple exciting
games i expect to pop up yeah we'll be
keeping our eyes on that right now
wesley in clear second but um of course
that could change
and this is he's playing against mvl and
of course uh vessel and topolof playing
against the other player lavon aronian
who's really fighting hard with wesley
for second place in the tournament vishy
needs a lot of things to for him
to go
uh well for him uh to gain second heel
hut and that will have to begin with a
win for him and a loss by his um and
that will be his height
yes
magnus not playing very theoretical so
far he he got himself into a little bit
of trouble in paris when he went for
this route against nakamura that one
game uh was a similar opening here
you mean the last one where he was
losing but one no the one where they
agreed to a draw where nakamura could
have pushed ah okay gotcha we have this
knight c6 a very famous isolated queen
pawn structure we're expecting at some
point this move d5 takes c4 to be played
a2 a3 back in paris actually
uh um
it was a voluntary retreat bishop e7 by
hikaru and c4c5 to avoid
the um
the traits
should be
probably going to happen absolutely i
think
a forced
uh
a forced play one might put it that way
you don't want to allow e5 exactly this
is strategically what you what you do
well i have a question bishop b5 knight
c3 rook c3 e5
knight c3 rook c3 e5 i think that's the
way to play in any case i have to play
rook e3 and allow e4
but i want to play uh
if i can keep if i can put my knight on
e5 and maintain it there i want to play
good knight versus that bad bishop just
continuing this line of play for just a
second case of e4 takes takes knight e5
um
double edge can i play queen e6 here
bishop b7 and prepare f6 or yeah yeah
that's definitely a line of play but
let's get back to the game itself
uh what's happened the knight c3 rook c3
has been played e5 has been played just
as you
well i think it's the only way because
we will take on c6 no matter what i
think i think the more normal move
actually i'll take back my move rook e3
and simply play castles here eric
so
castles e4 bishop c6 bc6 knight e5 yes
yes yes i'll play quincy seven instead
all right 95 attacking this pawn queen
c7 instead now i have to decide i think
i'm going to go king side with the move
rook g3
uh i'm essaying queen h i like it fi i
like i like what you're doing there okay
you like white what white uh white's
attack looks pretty scary yeah
especially yes it looks scary but
instead he played bishop g4 instead of
e4 which
probably is a better choice right
for sure
because this looks like mass trades we
might be headed into a fairly
equal end game here
i mean i don't see bishop c6 bc6 de5
bishop f3 and black recaptures on e5 in
the end
right no i mean
one thing i'll point out is nvl
sacrificed upon in typical english style
to just play a pleasant middle game but
he's down he's sacrificed upon against
wesley yeah
and uh
well a big question if i'm white here in
the game of magnus i think i'm looking
at queen a4
the idea is you better play bishop f3
and after rook f3
uh
i still haven't resolved
what if i play rook f3 then e4 and play
queen c7 f5 f4 just
push my pawns yeah it's still balanced
he has played in the very direct style d
takes e5
changing on f3 and after queen takes e5
b2b4
i don't think there's anything for
a5 is probably going to be played
getting rid of the isolation let's go
back to uh some of the other games
per second mvl offering an exchange by
the way so that he's down upon and he's
offering an exchange okay the big fight
is um i think that the lavon game is the
more interesting one right now you like
the little
of lavon
because this game of wesley so
well they're both interesting honestly
sacrificing an exchange in a pond it's
but yeah they're i've got the game of
wesley so mvl wessie slo so on my screen
we we've got queen d7 wesley reaching
for the d4 pawn and he has played it but
has he calculated all the tactics
yes i believe so
what do you mean well because after
knight takes d4 there's a bishop b7
issue but i think uh
you can take on d4 you can take 54
knight d4 94
bishop d4 bishop d4 bishop b7
the bishop d4 then
they don't see that then i'll just do
knight d4
i can allow you to take on g2 because
the knight on e7 is hanging and
yeah well the big question if white
doesn't capture this pawn then black is
a very handsome pawn to the good
if you play a move like bishop d2
what about this
knight on
the
yes he
basically had to take it knight takes d4
bishop takes d4 i think that's your
favorite phrase pawn to the good on the
game i i mean
well i live for pawns
and bishop takes
king takes
quick result and we have kramnik
defeating gary we'll have to look at
that later
yeah do you want to switch the
topologian as jennifer suggested that
one might have some tactics on the
king's side let's check it out because
ronyana
really wants to win in this position if
uh because that'll give him a good
chance at second place at least the tie
for a second right
okay i've got topolof lavon aronian so
what's your dream it's like a hedgehog
h6 reverb yeah well
well queen h
i'm thinking maybe you just want some
rook g6
as a potential
queen h5
it is white's move
so
well as white i definitely want to play
rook f1 to c1
basically i'm preparing an exit stage
left with the white king in case i have
to get on my running shoes
so aronya needs to win this game
otherwise he will not be in second place
very big shout out to wesley for a very
very credible result is this game over
too
yes it looks like a
repetition has been agreed bishop to g4
back to e6
very strange it just seems to show you
that these
players are
they don't like to take risks magnus has
taken more risk than any other i think
it goes to show you that they're very
successful in their lives though because
you know thirty thousand for second
third for fifteen thousand levon
couldn't care less
like it seems that way from the way
they're playing right you know because
because because it didn't matter he lose
he'd get fifteen thousand but then
he gets with ten thousand he draws he
gets fifteen thousand he wins he gets 25
or something so then why not play on
right you're saying that you really
logically should play on
yeah of course like it's a clear choice
by the way
somehow some way
magnus has blundered upon and he stands
upon down against ikar and nakamura well
this is interesting and but it doesn't
matter because grant has to our points
he risks if he loses lavon does risk um
dipping on and that's
exactly okay
and remember gary and alejandro both
maintain that lavon is a good
good pick um to win it all so that could
be very important for him
absolutely so rook e3 rook d4 i think
it's time to get an h4
uh so b3 critical move here king c3 and
after b2 i imagine magnus wants to play
rook b4 that's right not give up the
second so now i'm expecting rook e2
rookie 2 after rook d1 oh he played h4 i
thought he wanted to get in that move h4
just actually one move uh earlier i
guess it doesn't make too much
difference so with this rock can anand
catch
aronian with the win yes that's what i
think so he'll still tie for like three
quarters cannot catch wesley wesley
and b2
uh crucial uh move uh jettisoning the
b-pawn for the f pawn
uh did he karo and now after takes takes
g4 g4 but did you calculate the kingpin
end game already after one f
after f5
f5 king g7 yeah
that's
that's what i'm expecting hikaru well
after f5 do you take i don't think you
take i think we probably want to cut
play rook do we play rookie five or
something
king g7 works you still want to play f5
and king f6 right
so king d3 the natural move uh f5 is
official it should be should be in time
she should be in time and he's played f5
f5
basically box
no no if f5 would take king absolutely
we have to take
king f6 is
it said he shouldn't have taken and he
should have a lot played rook c4 rook a4
the engine felt that yes uh pretty
clearly we now have the cable base king
f6
king e3
rook f1
and he's taken an oh a very important
move by
magnus he just played the move rook e6
cutting off black's king
uh along the sixth rank so if we play
rook f6 we're in time we'll
just go into a dead drawn king and upon
the end game was king of six better
there for
and you mentioned king f6 king e3 rook
f1 but there was also king of yeah
that's the way to play he had to play
king e6 because i think
uh the position they've got in the game
uh oops excuse me i will refresh my
board
there's a king on f7 rook a6 was just
played right and if you play g4 you got
the king cut off but said king g2 is
enough yeah
rookie 5 trying to cut the white king
off king d4
but
rookie 1 king d3
so now the problem is if you advance the
g4 pawn then rook a4
and black's king cannot support the g4
pawn so he has to move his right to a
passive square like rook g1 and then
white's king can come exactly closer
oh this this is for sure
dead draw
there was one chance before with king f6
now no more and now anand and karwana
are still maneuvering there so we'll
build a fallout game after this game we
expect that game to finish uh drawn
vishy
has a lot to play for in this
game and if he ever wins a four pawn you
know clearly better oh he'll be up upon
but uh the knight on c5 is so good for
fabiano and he's like there's h4h5 ideas
that's right that's right i know i'm
pushing for sure here h4h5 i like that
that just seems easy to play just bring
just play h4h5
and try to
plant that knight
please don't please don't repeat please
don't repeat three thousand p moves so
far but
is that three faviano talking to the
arbiters at three moves
and he's letting his clock run i think
he's supposed to have stopped this clock
earlier
same claim or
faster or better yes exactly
and there's a champ um he's finishing up
and uh i believe that was a draw
and we'll indeed it was a draw so um
nakamura finishing with 16 and half
points in the tournament now the
question is i do think it was a draw
because it looks like they're chatting
about the game
uh essentially what uh
fabby wants to do is he's informed the
arbiter he's playing the move rook b6
to b8 as his intention and he's saying i
make it a three move repetition claim
uh vichy
disagreed
and the arbiters looked at the score and
in fact the fab fabby's claim was upheld
and a draw that was actually kind of
important for him
terrible i mean you shouldn't no reason
to allow that he's up on time and he has
a superior position that's why i was
upset
i mean
somebody allowed it oh yes yes
yes that's what i meant and it actually
does matter for probably because he lost
that game he would actually end up tied
with mvl this draw secures him um a
higher finish than mvl on the door
i mean
that's a clutch claim i always get shy
that in case i'm wrong like he had to be
pretty i mean he didn't have to be
really sure of it but like have we seen
the players don't always claim these
things during the game well as we saw
with the 50 move role for example yeah
well
the weird part about that
is that
for me
that
that draw
could have
a huge ramifications
down the line
in terms of grand p
pre-points because there's no way
that vishy considering the position he
was in going into the
this last round of what a victory versus
a draw meant was
enormous and so i'm sure she did not
realize that he was repeating three
times the problem for vichy is that if
he loses that game he finishes in fourth
if he draws that game he finishes in
four it literally made no difference
because whereas a win a win would have
catapulted him into a tie with lavon
for a third exactly so he had he was
really in a no-lose situation and the
money was all the same as well exactly
so um just nothing at stake except to
try to win exactly and he had a superior
position better time as well
but he didn't know all of that maybe
because he it's probably very difficult
to keep track of the other game going on
so he certainly didn't know the drawing
of course he doesn't know about that but
i mean for sure he understood what the
grand p points meant now as far as the
claim as far as the claim if the claim
was false
vichy might have gotten an extra time
but would not have been forfeited but we
have maurice ashley with the winner of
the leuven grand chester
the champ is here well he's world
champion we know that he's been the
number one player in the world for quite
some time now and he's added yet another
tournament illustrious wanted that to
his trophy mantle
magnus carlson first of all
congratulations on a win thank you how
does it feel to win this one you came in
second in paris not exactly your best
play but even here you made a couple of
mistakes but you managed to make it look
very easy at the end
yeah
so the difference this time was that
there was no
nobody like hikaru who
performed very well so
i didn't feel like i particularly stood
out
in this tournament except perhaps on the
second day of rapid but it was enough
didn't particularly stand out you won
almost all the games today you were
winning game after game you put together
something like a three or four game
winning streak to separate yourself from
the crowd yeah i know i i
i played there was a little
time today when i played well uh overall
it wasn't very consistent but
again i'm very happy that he was uh it
was enough rabbit and blitz uh done are
you kind of
i know i know you have a somewhat big
match later in the year are you kind of
not happy that you can't play in the
rest of the grand chess tour you would
probably win it even if you closed your
eyes and just randomly threw down moves
yeah that's that's a bit of a bit of a
shame but um
i mean with uh with the schedule the way
it is um
it would be too too difficult will we
see you next year on the tour
i hope so
what is your prediction finally for who
will win the tour now and now that
you're no longer a part of it
the standings of the players we have
hikaru having won paris and wesley
having come in second place in here with
lavon and anand chasing him um yeah i
think uh lavone and icaru have a have a
good chance wesley as well but i i would
um
think i love maybe levon is the favorite
well thanks so much and congratulations
once again we always appreciate having
you watching your play and of course
having your interviews thank you
magnus carlson the man for a reason
dominating the field today showing why
he is indeed the number one player on
the planet thank you maurice and again a
hearty congratulations to magnus carlson
magnus carlson winning the tournament
with 23 points wesley so
taking session and taking home those
crucial 10 grand pre points with 20 and
a half half point behind the bone
aronian uh with 20 and a half point
behind him
vishy anon with 19 and a half what an
event jennifer indeed in a little bit of
a comeback for nakamura who's in the
basement for so long at least he gets
four grand three points grand tour
points exactly
which will probably be thrown out but
just in case for instance he were to win
um london and do poorly in st louis it
gives him a little cushion for his final
standings right absolutely
and
eric
some thoughts before we go to the
closing ceremony after a break
i just wish this event would go on and
on just some sort of death match i loved
watching it it was really fun to
commentate
absolutely it was a real blast and
speaking of commentating and thanking
people i mean there's been a lot of
people behind the scenes that made all
of this possible that's right i mean i
just have to say
a shout out to the whole production team
what can i say it's spectrum studios and
that is a company owned by randy
sinfield you might recognize the name
and we've got our fantastic director
here on set jen humer so um we'd love to
see her every morning absolutely and of
course we've got our crew in paris kevin
marcus and justin they're with alejandra
maurice yeah barista liz today
tom our
producer executive director
key tape for making all of the sound and
everything possible
john tammy aviv
in the truck
and tatia who's doing all the social
media for us here and mark also and
nicole
uh so many people to thank that before
we continue with that we've got maurice
with wesley so in louvain
one of the top ten players in the world
one of the top americans in the world
wesley seoul with a fantastic result in
second place only to magnus carlson
wesley first of all congratulations on
this result thank you and you must be
pleased this is probably one of the
better results of your career winning
coming in second place ahead of such a
great field yeah of course only second
to magnus which is uh
not bad at all of course i'm very
pleased with my second place uh in the
end it was very close it was pretty
close with the fight for the second
place but um and now that it's all said
and then i'm glad that it's over and uh
i finished i can also this is very
important for the grand gesture points
and uh
and uh yeah as one of the americans here
i'm uh
i'm happy and proud to be able to uh
to be able to leave the country up
indeed tell me you had talked about
strategy coming into this one you talked
about it in the rapid about not losing
what any other secrets that you you
figured out with from from paris to here
to improve this results you went up two
standings on the table
oh yeah well definitely uh
one is take one game at a time and to
take each game separately and second if
after you have a loss you immediately
forget about it and move on to the next
round because so you can you can change
the pass and what's done is done and of
course uh
of a lot of energy for for the blitz
games because
uh opening preparation is not as
important because my opponents uh you
know keep
keep playing something else than what i
looked at
and that's interesting i want to pause
there
what what do you do to keep the energy
up
what do i do to get the well not to look
too much at the computer you know not
not to spend
the day before uh looking at lines for
four six hours a day
and
also having a lot of
a lot of sleep
unfortunately it's been a little warm
last night but
also and then i uh you know i'm i was
very excited to start the games today
and i managed to keep my energy level
just sufficient enough to to finish in
second place ultimately i could have
done better but again everyone could
have done better
absolutely we want to congratulate you
on a great result thank you and i also
like to thank the sponsors and
for making this wonderful event happen
of course it's not every day that we
play blitz and rapid
tournaments
and i look forward to the next leg in uh
in st louis which uh
it will be all it will be a completely
different tournament because of the
of the change in time but there will be
a classical time control and well we're
all looking forward to st louis we loved
louvin but uh st louis is home so we'll
look forward to seeing you guys there
again congratulations yeah grandmaster
wesley sauna fantastic finish finishing
second place in a tournament that
featured all the best players in the
world
thank you maurice and again big
congratulations to wesley so who had
been such a consistent player and a very
deserved second place that's right and
to uh round out the thank you speaking
of at home in st louis
eric and brian
our fantastic sound guy brian and eric
who's got the most coveted graphics wow
beautiful you saw all of those intros
it's just fantastic
and he also feeds us donuts so yeah that
makes him popular julie bray um the
general manager here at the chess club
who um in the chair well always
chess and tony rich goes above and
beyond both of them tony rich actually
in leuven and paris um um are just uh
passionate advocates for the grand chess
tour
um nicole mark leonard who you see all
this great photography and including on
the grout and chess tour on twitter feed
you can see tata is picking out some of
his most beautiful shots definitely
check that out at our hashtag um grand
chess tour and our twitter feed
grandchild store finally spry digital
the entire staff at the chess globin's
classic center graham jurgensen who's
the technical director of the tour and
david cedric who is the chief arbiter of
the grand chester and i gotta say there
weren't that many disputes so david did
a pretty good job absolutely absolutely
indeed and well done and thank you all
because that does make these broadcasts
so much more enjoyable and great for us
we just love it it has been a blast
and we had some final thoughts from
grand master eric hanson
i just gonna say it was a lot of fun and
feel free you know to tweet any comments
criticism things to improve that's the
first time
these last two tournaments paris and
luvin doing this format and i'm sure
we're going to do more of it so we'd be
happy to hear as much feedback as
possible and improve on that experience
next time
let me just get
one quick shout out if there was one
thing i would change about these two
events i would have a fifth day and i'd
break up those rapids so that there
would be three rounds of rapids over
three consecutive days so five games of
chess would be my choice then if you're
gonna have a fifth day we'll have a
sixth day where i just beat you
for 20 hours
one might as well make it six that
doesn't sound so much fun yeah i like my
suggestion better
and i do agree with your suggestion and
because i think that um some of the
players kind of by necessity pace
themselves a little bit so i think we'd
see even more sizzling chess
of course it would take an extra day
which can be hard for scheduling and for
the organizers but i think it would be
worth it
on the board itself yes
and we've got some final thoughts from
alejandro and maurice in the lubin
before the closing ceremony
well it was an absolutely fantastic time
here in leuven of course we had a
wonderful time in paris as well these
back-to-back events
blitz rapid
thrill spills all kinds of craziness
alejandro we had fun this was quite a
trip to be here on the european tour i
mean i think this was just amazing the
combination of the fast chest of
blunders the action i mean i don't think
i'm ever gonna forget annan's queen c7
brilliancy just to kick off the rapids
here in logan the organization was out
of this world among all the tournaments
i've been to this has been absolutely
top notch what a wonderful event to be
part of really yeah totally they they
fed us well they treated us well felt
like stars running around paris and then
here in lubin you you could tell you can
feel the energy for chess here of course
in europe they just love their stars
here and i mean they're like rock stars
and people come out the crowds that came
out to see them and now we get to see
them go to st louis but certainly we're
going to miss this place oh absolutely
we're happy to go back to the capital of
just in america it's going to be a
different fight we have the rapid and
blitz here players falling out of energy
just on day three on day four st louis
it's going to be a much longer event
longer time controls they have to get
back to that rhythm it's going to be a
different experience all together and as
i said as magnus said anybody can still
win the event
absolutely and we want to thank everyone
here that joined us of course my partner
in crime alejandra ramirez i can tell
you this guy was getting trouble so
often it's not even funny but tony rich
came all the way from st louis we have
the crew
with marcus and kevin and justin and we
just all had a blast and we look forward
to the next time we're able to give you
the feel from across the pond the
atlantic but we loved it and we hope you
did too
thank you
thank you maurice and alejandro just as
going through my mind thoughts about the
wild card player
magnus carlson and i really like that in
st louis for
our wild card will be the chinese number
one player ding laren
maybe a little bit not so well known to
the american audience that he's an
extraordinarily gifted talented player
from china and he will be our wild card
eric what do you think about ding
laren's presence uh in saint louis i'm
really looking forward to it you play as
the king's indian a lot of exciting
openings but i wanted to give one more
shout out last but not least we wanted
to mention thanks to jeannie and rex
singfeldt for helping make all this
possible everything that's going on
they've been big support
absolutely no question about it rex
we call it the sinkfield effect here in
st louis because it's been so meaningful
not only for saint louis itself but the
entire country the u.s championships
have been held here now eight times in a
row they'll
go on ninth next year and there we see
some
some of the uh autographed hounds
uh that's right we got uh all of our
players signing autographs quite
graciously and um remember that was not
just about the chess club it's there's
an actual chess campus and that's what
vishy anand um mentioned in interviews
that he likes about this place there's
the trifecta if you will the kingside
diner the world chess museum the world
chess hall of fame and then we have the
chess club so you can visit all three
when you come here i'm on the board
actually at the museum and it's always
so exciting that the exhibits just
rotate yeah and there's always something
fun
and again we're just getting uh set up
for the closing ceremony as we're
awaiting uh some of the speech making
but once again i just i'm just so
stunned by the beauty and grace elegance
of the two playing halls that we saw in
paris and this one in luven especially
uh just extraordinary
i know as a player myself i just loved
great playing venues and these are two
of the best i've ever seen in my life
that's right absolutely you could
certainly hear a rook drop from the
ceiling that is for sure those high
vaulted ceilings and
amazing murals uh paintings on the walls
yeah um it's been a really memorable
this tournament i mean for for for
better and for worse alejandra mentioned
this is a stunning game by anand with
the uh
queen c7 ended up on h2 maneuver and
there's also been all the spills even by
the champion in the completely
uncharacteristic game against naca right
i also think of the game that mbl failed
to win against nakamura but that was a
really beautiful game and i just was
thinking about all of those people who
love
collecting autographs we had that shot
just a minute ago of like magnus carlson
all the way down top top grand masters
in the world and gary kasparov being the
book and marker wouldn't it be nice to
get all of those players autographing
your favorite momentum
once yes that's the way you that's the
way it's done you got to come to saint
louis and we've got autograph sessions
and they're usually packed with a lot of
kids so you're going to have to help
because we are at classic center too you
have to elbow a few eight-year-olds to
get your autograph
oh and it just looks like uh speech
making is underway so we'll go back to
louvin
and it is
the tournament has ended
after four days
grueling battles
and we have now a closing ceremony
before i hand it over to
mr malcolm payne i would like to remind
you or let you know that over the four
days
we had about 1500 people coming in here
and watching the games live
online and we just made a calculation we
have over about 300 000 people who have
viewed these three days online so this
is wonderful and it's a big promotion
for chess now
thank you
[Applause]
to start to start with the official
ceremony please welcome mr malcolm payne
[Applause]
thank you jan
on behalf of the grand chess tour
just like to say how delighted we've
been
with this fantastic venue here in the
city of love and this historic building
that you can see around you with this
wonderful artwork
and it's a building that goes back to
the 15th century not quite as old as the
game of chess but we felt
that we were in a truly historic setting
of one that was absolutely perfect for a
chess tournament and we have indeed had
a wonderful chess tournament so our
thanks to the city of leuven for
providing i think one of the most
beautiful venues i've ever been to for a
chess event
[Applause]
i'd also like to thank the organizing
team here in leuven and also the chief
arbiters for ensuring that everything
went very very smoothly and also a great
thank you to the people that young pate
mentioned just earlier
are thousands and thousands of viewers
online the tournament wouldn't be
complete without you we aim to give you
a top-class chess broadcast the grand
chess tour is all about bringing chess
to the widest possible audience not
restricting the flow of the moves and of
information and of the entertainment and
the brilliant chess so we hope that
you'll come back to our next tournament
which will be in st louis in august the
scene field cup and also the climax of
the tour the london chess classic
now of course we'd also like to thank
our sponsors the your next move
foundation of which we'll hear more soon
but first i'd like to
invite to the stage the inspiration
behind the grand chess tour
and we're delighted that he's able to
come
to this challenge in leuven for the
closing ceremony please welcome the
world champion the 13th world champion
gary kasparov
[Applause]
thank you malcolm
thank you
thanks
it's truly historical moment and uh you
know while making history couldn't find
a better more appropriate place than
this phenomenal hall um five years ago
actually i was here you know moving
pieces was nigel at this stage and i
couldn't even dream that you know we'll
have such a phenomenal event of all the
best players uh competing and uh you
know
giving it this excitement
and joy for
hundreds of thousands of
chess fans around around the globe
it's um it's
phenomenal place to be and it's it's a
beginning of a new tradition
and i feel that my main contribution to
the event was that many years ago i
became a friend of a man who was behind
the organization this event a great
chess enthusiast um who uh organized
many um chess events uh for kids uh in
in this country in belgium uh and also
helped me to set up kasparov chess
foundation in europe and now first time
you know uh put his efforts resources uh
and energy behind uh
the
world-class event so i would like to uh
pass this mic to my friend and chess
enthusiast and and chess sponsor and
great man who is um uh residing in
leuven and and wanted always to make
this city a center uh for um global
chess young calibers
[Applause]
thank you
thank you gary for these nice words
everyone i'm very happy to see you all
of here
a dream came true
to have the 10 best players
in a single room
and on top of that having gary kasparov
with them
i'm very happy after many years to have
organized chess events for children
that finally
we have
a big event organized in belgium in
leuven in a very nice city as you all
know
we are very happy and proud to be part
of the gct
is the first year
we are organizing it
together
and i'm very happy also
that the right formula was in fact in
place a blitz and a rapid
especially in this place a little
country with a lot of attention uh we
are very happy with the organization and
the team with me and young potay they
did absolutely a fantastic job i can
tell you we have many things to do
simultaneously
like in chess but from an organizational
point of view i think this was
absolutely excellent
so now
[Applause]
so now i would like to hand it back to
our friend
about
the distribution of some gifts for the
winner
or a winner one or two or three but we
all know it's one big winner
thank you jan uh before we hand over uh
the prize to the victor the spoils first
of all i'd like to introduce all the
players to the audience one last time
and if they could uh line up just behind
me in the second row in the same way we
did at paris first please welcome former
world champion veselyn topalov
[Applause]
and from holland anish geary
from russia former world champion
vladimir kramnik
from the usa the winner of the first
grand chess tour tournament in paris in
2016 from the usa hikaru nakamura
[Applause]
third paris sixth here from france
maxine vashier lagrave
[Applause]
in fifth place to the lovin grand chess
tour tournament fabiano caruana from the
usa
[Applause]
in fourth place former world champion
started the tournament in the most
brilliant fashion vishyanand
[Applause]
in third place
10 points in the blitz ten points in the
rapid from armenia live on iranian
[Applause]
and in second place here at leuven
played extremely pragmatic solid but
also at times entertaining chess wesley
so
[Applause]
and now to
the winner i should point out that we
actually prepared
three trophies
um
for the winners are the winner of the
blitz the winner of the rapid and the
winner overall however
one man seems to have won them all
and rather than ask him to carry all
three
in which case i fear we might have a bit
of a disaster
i'm just going to ask jan calavera to
present uh the one for the overall
winner
and this is um
made of uh crystal by uh val san lombar
the other two i should point out here in
front of me are also rather lovely and
because we're in belgium of course
they're filled with chocolates i hope
you like chocolate magnus yeah he's got
a smile and these chocolates are by
marcolini so these two we'll put in a
little bag
and give to the magnus entourage to take
away but in the meantime i think let's
just award uh one trophy the trophy for
the overall winner of the grand chess
tour tournament at leuven it's a
beautiful crystal in the shape of
belgium young calabar please would you
present the winners trophy to the world
champion world number one magnus carlsen
[Applause]
thank you
okay ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much uh that concludes uh the formal
parts of the proceedings jan would you
like to say any more words yes the last
sentence is the following see you next
year
love it
a beautiful closing
for a great event and pretty vigorous
clapping there by lovatoronia and i
guess he loves this place he was happy
for his performance wasn't he and wow
what a very very nice setting again
simply stunning
and great play by magnus a pity is not
going to be on the grand chess tour for
the third edition uh
for the third tournament here in saint
louis oh but we're going to have fun
it's going to be a great tournament we
are including a dig loren and it's going
to be
just
two weeks of great chess there's going
to be ultimate moves again we always
love to see that
so whether you catch it in person or
you know just watch online make sure to
mark those dates on your calendar
and it's not too far away no it really
isn't this year it's in the summer so um
august 1st
obviously august 4th rather
we are going to be uh starting it all up
again in st louis but let's review the
final results of our tournament magnus
carlson
he has a 23 points he's
win this clear in every single section
as pointed out by malcolm he won the
blitz he won the rapid and of course
that means that mathematically he also
has to win the doorstop
but meanwhile wesley's so very solid
result in both events and he can be
extremely proud of his second place
finish um so we saw americans um very
high up in the crosstable in both events
of course nakamura winning paris and
wesley so coming second in moving great
job yeah and i just pointing out a very
balanced score by levon aronian to take
third place 10 in the rapid 10 in blitz
perfect 10. the perfect tense and we've
got eric hanson with his final thought
from illumine
thanks jen well i mean i
what can i say had a blast in my mind
the top two uh blitz
players in the world won each leg of
paris and luven so in the meantime i
expect to see a lot of the top players
sharpening their skills
and
until next time thanks everybody for
watching
bye guys see you in st louis bye bye
[Music]
you